foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
yo what is up everybody welcome welcome
back
it's another Saturday and we got some
exciting interviews to get into as you
all know y'all are here for a reason and
that reason is to talk to the top five
winners of the Endless engines 3D
challenge
um we're gonna just get into their
processes their creative processes
that's really what I'm interested in is
how each one of these individual artists
create in their own unique way and what
goes into a winning piece of art
um
for these challenges you know and it's
always tough pulling the winners is
always tough because there's so much
good art like each and every one of the
one of the top 100 artists could have
been a winner even outside of that you
know
um but we're here to learn we're here to
learn and and uh and learn from them
learn from their creative processes we
got five winners here we're gonna start
with Sam uh fifth place Sam Horton and
we're gonna go fifth fourth third second
all the way to First and we're gonna get
into their project files we're gonna get
into their references we're gonna get
into uh what inspires them we're gonna
get into the programs they use we're
going to get into how they got started
in 3D
um so if you guys are new to 3D or you
know if you're a seasoned 3D artist I
think there's going to be something for
everyone here I always learn a lot when
we do these so
you also have to bear with me here I
have a slight cold I don't know if y'all
can tell maybe maybe you can tell
um so yeah I'll just preface that but I
think without further Ado guys it's time
to get into it uh we're gonna start with
Sam Horton fifth place baby let's let's
switch on over let's do it
Sam hey what's up man how you doing
really really well yeah and yeah
beautiful day outside just coming to an
end so yeah nice to relax into an
evening and go through go through some
CG yeah yeah where are you based
so I'm in the Midlands of the UK so uh
just north of London basically
um cool yeah from the Deep South
Cornwall originally awesome man awesome
so for the people here do you want to
pull up your final your final piece of
art and just Loop it for us
that'd be awesome and then we can kind
of take a look at it and
um you know I got a ton of questions
even outside of the art but if you guys
have questions for Sam here we'll do our
best here
um and and maybe we'll turn it over to
you guys for a little q a
um so I'll preface you guys there I'm
gonna try and remember I got a lot of
questions myself but when we do that
just hit me with an app Punisher in the
live chat and then we can ask some
questions to Sam but
um so Sam
this this piece of art is incredible
your photorealism is on point your
simulations with the sand and dirt are
on point and the missiles like the
explosions there's so much going on
um
what program are you using these days
so I've been in 3ds Max for like eight
years or so uh it's the first thing I
ever started using um because at the
time it was uh blender was still just
sort of coming up obviously millions of
people using it but when I asked around
I was told 3ds Max is where you want to
go and whether that was right or wrong
who knows but it was it's treated me
well in that time uh I basically started
using it because uh well I went to UNI
to do product design
okay nothing to do with CGI and there
was a project where we meant to film a
little video of our product and I
thought oh I'd really like to animate
mine like how hard can 3D animation be
to get into yeah and uh so yeah I
started learning 3ds Max to do to do
just that one little project and just
sort of stemmed from there so that's
great no that's great it's
you know
um right now
you know probably since the beginning of
the year to be honest like I've been
reading all these books on creativity
and like where creativity comes from and
all this and that and um
you know I think it comes down to doing
stuff because it's fun and it sounded
like in your case you you know you did
it because
it sounded like a cool idea at the time
right um it's just something fun but now
like do you do 3D for work or is this
just a hobby or what
so I'm a I'm a toy designer I still do
product design basically I do all of the
sort of stuff I do basically contract
work for Lego and Hasbro and Mattel and
things like that oh wait dude contract
work that I yeah I know people always
get very excited about like oh
do you make any toys do you just play
with toys all day and yes pretty much
yeah have you seen Spaceballs like yeah
yeah yeah that's great
oh man that's cool so like you you
design do you design the Legos
uh I've nothing that's come out yet
nothing that I can talk about I've done
like a whole load of different products
I've done Nerf guns I've done baby toys
I've done Star Wars the little baby
odors and the robots from Star Wars have
all been turned into toys so I've done
all of those obviously it's part of like
a wider team wow that's become more
animation based recently so sort of my
role has become design the toy and then
animate it to show it off uh and create
like a little short film to show off
what it does and how it works
that's awesome I love it so you're
integrating 3D into your work your the
career side of things because your
passion has you know pushed you for you
said six years seven years you've been
uh I've been in this job for six years
and so I've been doing it as a I've been
doing 3D professionally for probably
five of those gotcha got you that's
amazing man yeah I know
um your scene is is incredible we had
you so for those of you
um who don't know basically you know we
hold these challenges and uh it's about
a month long where you get everyone has
a month to do uh The Prompt right and
every Monday we meet up on the Discord
server
um which if you want to join there's a
link down below and uh basically we hold
these like these just little meetups on
Discord and we have artists come up and
they show their work and it's like
unfinished work here you go yeah this
was like week one wasn't it or week two
I don't remember yeah this was week one
of the challenge yeah it was yeah early
yeah dude that what a perfect timing uh
and I was already I was blown away by by
this at such an early you know you're
only a week in but you really seem to
like how did you get this busted out so
quickly
so if I show you this I mean this will
start to look like cheating but this was
a shot that I made in
2019 yes okay
this was me learning CG so this little
robot character has been my little guy
for years like I've created him straight
out of uni yeah um and then I wanted to
basically design a speeder for him and
build a whole environment for him
um but then I took like a year or two
off from doing sort of personal projects
and I had done nothing really on it for
a long time and then I was on a work
trip in Germany it had been a like awake
for like 50 hours or something it was
exhausting and your video dropped
showing this endless engines competition
and I showed it to a couple of
colleagues and they were like oh you
have to you have to get in that you
surely like you can reuse these old
project files I thought uh these are
kind of a bit rubbish the the quality of
the models and the quality of the
textures are a bit nah
so I basically end up in the first
couple of weeks just set about
completely rebuilding everything so new
new scopes for everything retexturing
everything
um wow yeah it was kind of a kind of a
whole
process of building out this guy up to
that level which was pretty much where
he was before and then there was a
repaint and then I didn't like that one
because it was too grungy and I
repainted again and it was too dirty and
I repainted again and I was kind of
happier with this sort of final cleaner
one so I basically just did this the
whole time over and over again with all
of the old assets was to completely
re-model them and then re-unwrap and
re-texture everything to get it feeling
right wow that's incredible I mean it
just goes to show that like if you guys
keep creating if you keep
you know practicing what you love you're
like when the time comes you'll be ready
you know because if you didn't do that
in 2019 then you know you may not
have entered the challenge who knows you
know like you yeah exactly you you were
at least at a point where and good on
your friends too for like pushing you to
to do that they saw
you know and good on you for listening
yeah yeah friends Jack and Dom were very
excited about the idea of me doing this
like were there behind me the entire
time pointing and waving at my screen
pretty much
now that's great it's it really goes to
show like I just want to highlight that
you know everything Stacks right so you
know today you might not feel
ready I don't know whatever that
whatever that would mean but then a year
or two from now
even stuff you did years back can still
help you today so it all adds right um
and you never know what's gonna happen
or where it's gonna go so all you know
is that you can just
have fun with you with your with your
passion and and see what it morphs into
you know
um and it morphed into something really
really cool so you are in 3ds Max my
goodness I hadn't seen this layout in
ages wow um
it's been yeah it's been a long time I
used to use 3DS uh for maybe like six
years
um
it was a long time actually
but I I am getting carried away here
walk us through your scene what's going
on here
chaos mainly yeah
a mess of a file
um yeah this is like the the raw
animation you know it's the the
background isn't actually moving I I
found that most of my uh blockout work I
did
um I just put a video of your scene in
the background
and I sort of just matched the animation
and pacing to that uh just to try and
feel it out and uh that was a little
trick I learned along the way it was
doing everything stationary uh just
really gave it a lot easier to do the
simulations and things if you're moving
at 200 300 miles an hour along a long
stretch uh the uh fabric Sims just go
bananas and a smart fly around all over
the price so it became a thing to
simulate everything still animate
everything still so I can get a feel for
things obviously then as you're
animating your your camera's not
shooting off and your vehicle is not
flying out of frame every time you want
to do a minor tweak so sort of isolating
everything still before trying to adjust
it to the Earth of moving on through the
scene kind of thing that's a great tip
you know you because the more elements
you throw in to to like
add to the chaos of especially a
simulation you want to really
kind of limit it to
the known factors and uh the more
variables you introduce it could you
know then you're just troubleshooting
more and more so that's smart to to lock
it down to the center just focus on
exactly what you're trying to do for the
simulations here
um because technically they would you
know I'm sure you're using like wind you
have like a little like yeah yeah yeah
that's that's that's perfect
um so was was animation this and simming
this was that your first first kind of
thing
yeah I pretty much just started with
making out this shot just to feel out
everything I I had a vision of what I
wanted to make it loop I had a vision of
what I wanted the environment to be and
what I wanted the story to be but before
I committed to what I knew was going to
be
four or five weeks of work I wanted to
know that I was up to the task of making
motion that I was happy with and feeling
out basically a lot of the early problem
solving um just wanted to see that I
knew what I was doing before I tried it
now did you know like what the
background would be and all this at this
point or like how how much of a final
version of this in your head did you
have at the beginning versus just kind
of going with the flow and feeling it
out as you created
uh I knew I always wanted it to be him
running away from something and I knew I
always wanted it to be sort of density
and martiany
um it sort of goes into a lot of old
work that I've done with this character
he's always been situated in a sort of
reddish desert area yeah so I wanted to
carry on with that theme
um but I did go in several different
directions early on trying to work out
what I wanted it to feel like
um
yet not all to great success there's a
lot of there were a lot of bad ones
early on yeah I mean you can't you can't
nail it every time you know
it's tough when you're just trying to
play around mess around and also like
try it try to have it be as perfect as
possible those two things are often hard
when put together
but that's great yeah right here when
talking to you you said about having the
uh like something else going on The
Chase and that was good to hear about
just the reaffirming of yeah I do want
to have something else
yeah in this scene to make it feel more
exciting yeah I didn't know what I was
um so sorry I cut you off there
um
um we found in the top 100 a lot of them
had a second thing happening they had a
you know either a halfway point
story element introduced or they had uh
like something else going on in the
background it wasn't just hey look at
this car look at this vehicle and then
let's get out of here it was like
there was more than that and uh you know
it's cool to know that
in your mind you're like okay we gotta
add it can't just be this there's got to
be a little bit more to the scene here
um
so when when you're at this point you
know you're about a weekend
uh where do you go from here you know
like this to a lot of people this might
look done you know a lot of people would
be like this is my submission
but you had you know three and a half
weeks ahead of you
um what do you do from here
so I think when when I talked to you and
you had suggested uh like something
behind it coming along just sucking up
all of this dust and dirt and debris
and I thought that was sick and I had no
idea what that vehicle was going to look
like basically so I had a couple of
different goals at modeling things and I
couldn't quite come up with a feel
um
and I didn't really want to use any like
uh or too many like kit bashed elements
for my hero objects
um yeah eventually as it was getting
into the week and mad work projects to
get done I sort of committed to
developing the um
the little drop ship which is a whole
load of Kit bash 3D elements from the
mission to Minerva as well as a whole
load of other little trusses and missile
elements and things
so yeah yeah okay so is that is that the
the drop ship from the Minerva pack like
with stuff added or is it just the drop
ship from the pack it's had stuff added
and I redid the EVS on it so I could
repaint it in my own color scheme and
things just to uh yeah bake it into the
world a little bit better add the same
sort of red and white uh split tone
color scheme going on yeah yeah
and the missiles man like what is this
all in one project file or are you
splitting this up into different project
files yeah this is all one project file
so this is like a more so the the
missile scene is actually just lots and
lots of circles uh with pictures of
smoke on them to keep it lightweight
um so they're all just set to always
Face camera
um the system if I go back to the scene
file but not that scene file so it's
emitting transparent images
yeah so if I go here you can see that
the Dropship has a turret the turret is
always tracking the uh ship itself yeah
but just a little bit behind so it's
always got like a it's got a look at
constraint on it basically yeah because
it's animated through in this simulation
it's told to spawn
all sorts of different images basically
all the time so the missile is a 3D
geometry but everything else is just
lots and lots of circles
what that's crazy yeah so you can see it
more there as you go around but it's all
just
lots of circles you know there's not
even circles you're talking discs
yeah yeah discs yeah they're all 2D
geometry just totally space the camera
same as uh the ground hit explosions are
just slowly growing explosions with uh
again some debris generated as it as
they get the ground dude
um so that's that's such a great idea
wow
that's so cool it's a it's a really cool
system in Max I think everyone who uses
Max now has this tire flow plug-in
installed yeah yeah
um and it's just fantastic for being
able to quickly build out simulation
work and this whole missile system is
just one system that generates missiles
generates muzzle flashes generates smoke
trails and then checks to see whether
it's hit something and on that will
generate some debris and some dust on
the hits that's crazy really robust
little system so this is something you
set up or this was something that was
like already made
no this is my setup yeah wow node by
node and then hoping that each addition
actually made it better and not worse
that oh man that I could get lost in
that like in just you know set up a cool
system that works and puts out a cool
visual thing like that is that's fun how
long did that take to set up
that was well the the base setup was
probably done in a day or two but then
it was tweaked for the entire time I
mean the community on the Discord was
really helpful here there was a lot of
uh comments that were like the Smoke's
just looking too uniform or it's looking
too wavy all the hits aren't quite right
and so somebody I wish I could remember
who it was it might have been like ice
cream man or something like that Jess
said about putting some noise onto the
circles as they generated and so that
was I think one of the biggest uh
changes to happen was to have this uh
extra swirling happening as the as the
uh as they come down dude that is crazy
that that is just a bunch of discs it
looks great
lighting helped as a lot of tricks and
bump mapping each of the circles helped
as well to keep them
to keep them feeling right and then just
a lot of uh After Effects and da Vinci
masking to make it interact with the
ship a little bit better especially
punches through the hole
so what do you have do you have a render
of like
uh before you hit post
um
uh not post-production do I have
basically post-production
just your yeah your raw render and then
and then your final to kind of see what
you did in After Effects or da Vinci
I might be able to find it quickly it's
about I've done uh
what is it gonna be and we're gonna take
it here we're gonna take it to in our
last 10 minutes we're gonna take it to
the the chat here if you guys have any
questions for Sam
um man that's 30 minutes flu jeez uh
that was ridiculous uh we're gonna take
it to the chat if you guys have any
questions for Sam at Punisher in the
chat so I can like see the little orange
little thing the orange tag and then uh
we'll throw some questions from you guys
to Sam as well because I'm sure you guys
have some good ones
so this is the
um comp file so the uh I rented it in a
couple of different passes for the
circles uh causing the smoke I actually
rendered as a separate pass completely
and can't come in afterwards because uh
the number of transparency phrase that
were required to render it cleanly was
really high and I wanted to approach
type this element of the scene a lot
more than having the uh circles chugging
down the render yes every time I wanted
to iterate absolutely
um same with the ground smoke and all of
those effects and all of these small
Jets coming off the vehicle they're all
separate Phoenix FD Sims done in other
magazines and then rendered out
separately in like v-ray and brought
back into after effects to come back in
okay got you got you
um
how long did you give yourself to put
all of this together do you have like a
week do you have a day what was it
uh just the comping yes
the comping was
uh yeah it was about an evening a long
evening but it was about an evening it's
all came together quite easily just from
yeah having everything rendered from the
same camera the whole time and mirroring
lighting setups across render engines
made things really easy
um there wasn't a lot of color
correction that needed to be done
because of that and stuff that's great
when it all comes together so easily
like that is just wonderful
um let's uh let's take it to the chat
here and see if you guys have any
questions for Sam again hit me with at
Punisher
uh that way I can see them
let's see we've answered a lot of these
already how long have you uh been
working in 3D
yeah about well about five years I've
been working professionally doing it
uh okay xero has a question how can he
learn 3D fast
and It's gotta be a fast answer too
the first answer is to go and watch Ian
Hubert's Quick videos and then go and
watch a guy called Jesse patella's
simulation stuff and go and watch
Southern shorties uh little how to
animate things quickly videos just Speed
Run YouTube tutorial that's good can you
say those three guys one more time
because that's that's good a southern
shotty Jesse patella in Hubert's those
are probably my three main guys cool
awesome awesome awesome uh
uh what made you get into 3D I think
we've covered that as well didn't we
yeah just a an inkling that maybe it
would be easy and and being wrong for
like six years
they want to know what render engine
this is
this is redshift for the most of it and
then v-ray for smoke and dust hits
which is actually probably the wrong way
around to do that so don't take my
advice Regis a lot better at smoke and
dust and V raise a lot better
environments but I did it backwards
all good uh uh Michael says what's the
name of that little robot guy
he's called Huey after uh the guys from
uh Silent Running
I don't know
oh you've ever seen
this uh classic movie this was a lot of
my inspiration there's little robots
that just exist to take care of plants I
love that that's a good idea
one of them that was killed during the
movie was called Huey and uh I've always
had an attachment to that as a character
that's cool
was that 80s movie it looks like the
most 80s movie ever
yeah yeah it really is very
old-fashioned
uh let's see let's see
hmm
all right Fiji says do you have any
advice for art artist block or burnout
take a break
just don't work on something for a
little while and let the idea come to
you I mean if it if you're time pressed
for the best thing is I find to just go
and watch a movie or see something else
for a while and get inspired by that the
uh the block is definitely real and I
definitely have taken a fair bit of time
away from things before coming back to
even just do this project but uh yeah I
think seeing the Martian and seeing June
and things like that in the months ahead
of this was like big oh I want to make
those man we rewatched Dune maybe like
two weeks ago and it's like
oh oh my goodness I remember we were
watching The Last of Us TV show and like
that's a good show and but I was like it
still feels just like a TV show I want
something more and I was like dude I
remember that being amazing yeah oh my
goodness what up ah what a great movie
it is fantastic but you're right yeah go
watch a movie I was so inspired after
watching that I was like I've been
missing this in my life
yeah I feel like the number of CG
artists that went away and just tried to
remake flying dragonfly wings uh it was
pretty high
yeah that was so cool
um visual asks when are we gonna get the
collector's edition toy version of this
well actually I don't know if you can
see my camera right now
oh what there he is
oh my goodness
I feel like I've uh
I put him up to that but there's a work
in progress of the little
whoa little guy that's so cool
little poseable arms and things that's
awesome
wow that was
been the last uh little while of
deciding I wanted to have him as a
little statue on my desk to be able to
uh have him about as a slightly earlier
version that's so cool I love that so
there's more than one
oh I think in the world that this exists
in there would probably load to them
it's a bit like probably astromex in
Star Wars where they're all just utility
droids just doing jobs and things and
then
the toys themselves though like there's
more than one oh physical toy
oh yeah yeah I got a prototype maybe
maybe visual or reach out and uh and buy
one I'll release the 3D titles at some
point somebody can uh do a better job of
the cleanup than I did that's great
um I think we got time for one more
question in these last two minutes here
but Paul asks how did you manage uh life
and this project during this project
uh probably demanding friends suggesting
that we go to the pub instead of me
arguing no I need to get more work done
and I like just take a break and that uh
that helps a lot I think uh without
people putting things into perspective
sometimes so you can easily just go down
a rabbit hole of this stuff especially
when you have simulations and textures
you can just keep zooming in closer and
closer into each of those elements and
get lost in it and until somebody sort
of stands behind you or you show it off
on a Discord or something like that and
somebody's like no that's really good
anyway okay
I'll probably I'll leave that for now
and I'm gonna go go outside and do
something else for a bit yeah it's tough
to know where you're at when it's just
you
um you have no other reference points uh
but yeah getting out and
listening to your friends who are like
you know
get off your computer it's probably yeah
good move was it the same friends who
were like hey do this challenge
yeah they were they've been there the
whole way I mean when we did the uh you
did the 100 uh you know the winners
announcement we were all sitting in we
had a curry we had some beers oh we were
watching it and I kind of sort of wow
I've got top 100 this is incredible and
I've kind of relaxed into the evening uh
and then you show top five and they went
ballistics
that's so cool man wow Ah that's awesome
to hear you know it really is nice to
hear that stuff because uh we're always
just in the weeds with it you know so
it's cool to zoom out as well and get
that perspective too so that's that's
awesome but hey Sam we gotta let you go
um we're gonna hop in with David milor
is next
um doing the fourth place render so uh
much appreciated man thank you for your
time thank you for your patience thanks
for showing off all of this expertise
and uh that discs trick with the
emitters man that's a good one that's
really good
uh thanks very much and thanks for
putting on the competition yeah that's
the main thing really uh kicks everyone
in the in the butt to get doing things
that's great that's great I should I
should do the same I I didn't get I
didn't get a submission in this time but
it's okay maybe next time Sam thanks
again man we'll catch you soon
cool thanks very much guys peace
David it's David
what's up man how you doing uh-oh I
don't hear you
oh crap yeah we see we're all in a
Discord channel right so that's how
we're hearing each other in real time
where you at David
oh there we go okay here I am hi
hello what's up yeah I hear you I hear
you I hear you okay cool switch back to
your to your art
there you go yeah you built out a whole
thing how's it going sweet good man how
are you I made a whole a whole
presentation whole business presentation
for this
I love it take it super serious I'm good
how are you doing I'm great I'm chilling
you know I have a little cold but I'm
enjoying some tea uh and um
yeah hanging out so it's good it's a
good time yeah
I'm just coming off my little uh I had a
little bit of a funk last week as well
so I know I know that feeling indeed
um yeah so you are gonna be at NAB
coming up uh April
what 15th through like the 20th or 19th
or something yeah yeah I I think I'm
presenting on
Monday so I think that's the 17th yeah
Monday at once on booth
yes sir yeah
um and I'll be talking about uh a
process very similar to what it did for
this which was I've been creating stuff
using VR and then I bring it into C40
and I do all my lights and uh shading
and just kind of give it life inside of
there whoa that's a very unique approach
that's crazy yeah
what um
what what what
gave you that idea to start doing that
oh gosh
um
VR modeling has been around for like a
couple years now but I never really got
into it I tried medium a couple years
ago and I just could not
wrap my head around it I think part of
it was just like
it was it was a new interface to to
navigate right so
um I tried it on like a project or two
and I was like uh maybe not right now
um and then when substance 3D modeler
came out last year which was like the
the VR desktop modeling hybrid I was
like oh this sounds really cool I could
get into this where I could do like a
little bit of a little bit of both in
the same program
uh well what ended up happening is that
I liked the navigation in modeler in the
VR space so much that I just only made
stuff in VR and didn't even bother with
the the desktop portion of it oh cool
um yeah and then I would just take my
models and you know run them through
zbrush or anything to to clean up the
the meshes and then bring them into
Cinema 4D and
uh give give like more life to it and so
I just kind of found my style uh through
doing that that's amazing that I love
that it's a
it's a really unique approach you know I
I've heard of it I've never messed with
it myself I always you know I think I
saw Nico doing it at one point
um just just for fun just to you know do
like a little painting or something I
think he actually did it in one of the
render challenges we did with people
um he he used that and um
I thought it was interesting you know
but I didn't know that your setup was
you know your piece of art was done
using VR modeling that's crazy so what
obviously you need a VR headset right
and yeah yeah so I got a I've got a rift
ass
um yeah
um and like I know there's some newer
versions out right now this one works
perfectly fine
um
and
yeah substance 3D modeler is the program
I use I started playing around with
quill recently and that's a lot of fun
because you can kind of do
uh like like
it's almost like using Adobe animate but
in 3D or like flash yeah
um wow
yeah did you start oh sorry go ahead I'm
so sorry
oh no worries I was just gonna say that
it's it's fun because it kind of blurs
the line between like physically
creating something and uh creating
something digitally because you're
you're building with your hands and your
arms and you're using your face to kind
of move around uh as if you were to
sculpt something in real life so that's
one thing I really like about it yeah I
you know I'm I'm a very kind of Hands-On
person I love like so for example I I
love playing music I love playing the
drums of course that's very Hands-On
um yeah but when you sit me behind like
a keyboard with minty drums uh in like
Ableton or something I'm like this feels
so wrong I don't like this I I want to
be hitting the drums I want to be moving
my body and uh
yeah you know I can see how the same
thing applies for for art you know um
how often do you say like
go to a coffee shop or something and and
draw because you enjoy drawing right
I do enjoy drawing um and I have I have
my Sketchbook and I have like an iPad
that I sketch on
um I don't go to coffee shops all that
much I'm not a big coffee drinker but
this is a place regardless of the place
but you know
um no but I do I do like to sketch a lot
at home
um and like if I go over to friend like
a friend's house or something I'll bring
my my sketch pad or something like that
and just we'll hang out and we'll throw
in a TV show and just sketch for a
couple hours or or whatever oh that's
great um and that's actually where like
a lot of the
a lot of this came from was it just
started out as just like a couple little
sketches
um but as I've gotten more into the VR
stuff
I've ended up doing a lot of my my
sketching and prototyping like on the go
in 3D uh in VR
you know what I just realized can you
can you Loop your submission here
um your art oh yeah yeah your submission
that that
yeah Loop the art here because uh people
people need to see what we're talking
about
so it started out as a sketch
little drawing uh just like some like I
started with the blocking out of like
the buildings and stuff like that but
then I was just over at a friend's house
and I just started sketching out like
the vehicle and like the character and
just
you know the inspiration Pinterest
surfing trying to get ideas for
what I wanted this whole world to look
like
it's looking a little laggy on my end
um and I think it's looking a little
laggy on the stream let me see if I can
just scream
can't sometimes my computer starts up
and doesn't recognize my main project
drive and this is one of those times and
I'm not restarting my computer oh no
boy
uh how bad is it because it looks fine
on my end
um it's choppy you know people are
getting Still Still frames you know
every every while it's okay though it's
okay don't worry about it
um people get the idea people get the
idea it's beautiful like it's very
vibrant
um
I guess
I have so many questions but let's start
from the beginning how did you come up
with this idea
uh so I'm a I'm a big anime games nerd
so
um I loved I love all the the vehicle
designs and like the proportions that
Akira tournament Toriyama uses in Dragon
Ball
what is it called sand lands the other
short series he has
um so I just immediately was like okay I
want to make something that's a tribute
to that style of work sweet so this was
like a very
a very like condensed form of the the
inspiration that I got for the bike
um and then with the buildings
uh like we've been to Japan a couple
times and I I love like dude the variety
of buildings and all the big neon signs
and stuff like that and so I really
wanted to create something that was had
a little bit of a futuristic flavor to
it but uh felt very much like a Japanese
uh like futuristic coastal town yeah I I
love space reference here is beautiful
um the pixel art on those buildings like
that third one with the traffic cones
and the moss on it like that is yeah I
love this amazing oh yeah and what's
that one with the 82.99 what is that
from
oh that is
um it's from an artist uh art hiraputra
I think is how his name is pronounced uh
he's done a lot of uh music videos for
artists um one of which is have you
heard of uh crystal dolphin by Englewood
okay definitely check that out uh he did
a music video for for that for him for
that and it turned out amazing because
it's just like it's it's all 3D but it's
got these super flat vibrant colors and
oh it's just eye candy every frame of
the crystal dolphin by yeah Inglewood
Englewood yeah okay I'm just gonna with
an e
Inglewood all right I'm gonna remember
that that's cool I love music videos
it's so good
um no this is this is wonderful this
gets me amped just seeing this right
here
um
yeah that's beautiful
yeah
um and then one of the things that I
once I figure out the setting for for
this world that I was building
I was trying to figure out what time of
day I wanted and initially I was gonna
do like like a bright sunny day along
the coast but
I ended up deciding on like a sunset
because I really I really wanted all
those nice warm pinks and oranges and
yellows uh Fading Into more like a
darker blues and purples to just
uh just give that scene a lot more more
richness to it
man this is uh making me feel stuff here
I love this is amazing I love this man
uh
those colors man geez those colors are
wonderful and I love that in the bottom
left down there too that's
so simple like I just want I want to
play games like this I think that's why
uh you know we've known each other for a
little bit and um you know we we got
really into that what was that game
yeah
yeah that game man like the design in
that game was super cool so it's cool to
see like I love that yeah
I love it man all right I'm I'm I'm I'm
down for the ride uh yeah um and also
just you know like we both went to
camograph last year and every day we'd
go out to the
the whole group would go out to the dock
and watch the the sunset every night and
it was just like I love
that color palette it's the best it's
just yeah it's so relaxing
all right so yeah where do we go oh yes
yeah so sketches so like I said I didn't
do a ton of like I didn't have like a
whole like sketch
I didn't have a whole smattering of
sketches for the characters and the
vehicles I kind of
I had an idea of what I wanted to do
from the inspiration and I did like a
first pass of a character in a vehicle
and then I was just like all right this
is good I just want to start sketching
in VR and so this is where I started
with with these guys
um I'll get to this little this little
manhole character uh once we start
diving into the c45 yes great
um
but yeah so like just the main character
uh just like
taking notes from like uh what is it
cyberpunk that that one video game uh
Slash series
having like an outfit like that and then
doing the the toriyama-esque like kind
of squash compacted uh motorcycle I love
that blocky look it's so adult
yeah it's already tangible here like
your render I feel like I just can like
bite it I just want to eat it but like
this right here I can I still feel like
I can like pull this off the page and
like play with it and feel those edges I
love that blockiness man it's great
yeah and and thankfully when I started
building this in VR it like translated
super super well so I was really happy
about that
uh and then here are some very initial
sketches of the the actual background
scenery
um
so
in this I had like a more
like future futuristic uh Vibe going for
it and as I started actually building
the
the seed elements I I wanted it to be
more like uh
feel feel a little bit more closer to
Modern and not like way too future
because this is like a it's a small town
on the coast it's not like gonna be
crazy developed like a major
metropolitan area so I wanted to have
like a little bit of uh
like like an old school feel to it this
is Advanced do you do this for every
project like are you really like you're
doing these drawings before you even
touch 3D like
uh sometimes I just go straight actually
a lot of the times I just go straight
into 3D yeah okay okay this is like very
well thought out
um and you're you're planning on
modeling all this versus pulling like
bash elements or yeah wow dude
yeah wow
um and then even all the the sign
Graphics I did by hand I just once I
once I built once I built all these
these sign elements over here and you
viewed them out I just created a bunch
of templates threw them all on my iPad
and I would just
sketch them out and uh so there's
I forget how many
varieties of signs I did this is like
the bulk of them right here and so
some of them would just be original
illustrations that I would just kind of
play around with others would be like
the like this the dog I would take like
a 3D render and just do a really cool
stylistic Trace over that because I
really like that the element
man um but then I even I even made like
a a little glyph system
just by taking letters and kind of
making them Blobby shapes and adding and
subtracting different parts of a letter
and so this actually reads out endless
engines uh this this says dog oh I can
kind of see it yeah yeah
um and then this is just like a random
three letter word so I chose Ace for for
this part over here
jeez man um yeah and so that was really
fun and then I would take that uh so
these are like the base colors and then
what I would do is I would take that
when I brought it into Cinema 4D I would
set it up in a Shader so using a random
effector
I would drive like a little bit of a
color shift so sometimes this would turn
out to be like a reddish background and
sometimes it would be blue or just like
the regular green that you see here sure
because there would be there would be
multiple copies of these these signs in
the scene but I didn't want them all to
be the same because that would start to
get a little bit flat so
uh doing just like that little that
little trick to vary it up a bit helped
so much
that's amazing yes I'm already you're
already giving me ideas on how to use
c4d differently I yes
um and then here's the 3D so
um
yeah so this is in VR so what I did was
uh not not the painting stuff these are
snapshots from substance painter
um but what I did was once I had a
general idea of what I wanted to be
the character in The Bite to look like I
took the like a placeholder bike that it
had in the scene from very very early on
and sculpted my elements around the
character like the little
the the wood puppet
uh from from Cinema and also just like
some very general block shades for the
motorcycle and sculpted that out in
there
once that was good took it out of there
reach apologized it using just like a
very quick zero measure and then a quick
UV unwrap
brought it into substance painter and
then just sort of playing around with
different uh like custom Smart materials
in substance Banner it's a great like
the nice little
edgeware on the the bike and adding like
a little bit of like that
like the uneven paint
yeah all the imperfections and the chips
and stuff yeah yeah I got you yeah those
little scratches on the glass and as you
can see here like the the glass on the
bike was was way higher up initially and
one of them what I ended up doing is
because it was blocking the face
entirely in the final render I just
squished it down and it turned out just
fine oh that's great Instinct yeah good
good eye on that for sure
yeah
um and then here's here's some of the
buildings so again all made in VR
and then brought into substance painter
to do some some nice texturing dude so
cool oh ah I like this is such a great
workflow I love this this seems like so
different than what I'm used to in 3D
and that's great because I feel like I
need to mix it up at this point you know
I've done the same workflow for so long
and
you know I need to spice things up a
little bit this this is awesome I love
the the output of this is
very you know video gamey very cartoony
and I'm just such a sucker for that
because I've been doing photo real for
so long and uh
you know it's nice but I would really
like to start
getting into this kind of setup here
this kind of look man this is incredible
thank you
um for for this so once I had a general
idea of how I wanted the building
elements like the the paint on the walls
the the metal on the pipes all that kind
of stuff I just was able to save this
that is
smart materials and actually all the
materials that you see here and on the
previous page
once I had that system set up I was able
to kick out
all the materials for each model within
a day
whoa because because it's just like okay
I know exactly how everything wants to
look now all I need to do is just tweet
colors here and there and I've got what
I want for every scene
that's great yeah I need to learn
substance as well man geez I I I use
substance painter maybe once or twice
before in a project but I didn't use it
as heavily as I did with this and now
it's like I I can't go back cool it's
just too good cool that's awesome I'm
glad that you know people are learning
stuff through these projects that's the
that's the point so
yeah
here's some some very early Works in
progress
um so this is this is the very first
scene like like the day you announced
that that contest
um I download the project scene I was
just like okay I have a pretty I have a
pretty good idea of what I want to do I
want to do like the the semi-futuristic
coastal town like
very Japanese City pop future phone type
Vibes
um get a Cool Motorcycle in there so I
just start blocking everything out
um so here's like a first initial
blocking out this is like a near final
blocking out on the the right
uh for the cloud background I actually
used uh Houdini so I sculpted I I made
like a general volume in Houdini or in
in modeler
kick that out of there and brought it
into Houdini
and then there's a couple like little
note there's some nodes in Houdini that
can turn it into a like a cloud volume
and you can add noise to give it sort of
that
I guess that cloud look yeah
uh and you can also make a loop in there
too so I just oh cool set a little bit
up uh kicked out that volume and then
rendered it as like a back plate
for my scene so those clouds that we're
seeing on the bottom left are the clouds
in the final
uh this is an early version of it but
yeah got it got it got it
um and then this this bottom right
render is
uh like a early final-ish render where I
was discovering that I didn't want to
have like I when I rented this out it
was like oh it's it's looking a little
bit too cool for what I wanted I wanted
to bring back more of that warmth more
of those Reds in there yeah the signs
themselves were looking a little bit
blown out so
um
it was great to like have time I gave
myself enough time to be able to work
out those little kinks
uh that's good that's very important
yeah because like this right here looks
like a final render but for me it was
like no I this it's not like exactly
what I want so how much time do you give
yourself like in a project uh like
contingency time you know like you have
you what five weeks to do this and uh
did you have like a schedule that you
mapped out roughly like by week one on
one XYZ week two week three or did you
just kind of like go into the wind and
like kind of see what came came of it
it was a bit of that yeah
um I I worked on this like maybe
a couple hours a day like an hour or two
just sort of chipped away little things
just whatever I kind of wanted to
accomplish in the moment
um and I think it worked out pretty well
I think I could have done like a little
bit better organizing like okay I want
this done by this time and I sort of had
to to set those
those benchmarks
near the end of it because the last
couple days I I spent a lot more time
getting it finished up but
I I didn't feel rushed I didn't feel
panicked about getting it done it was
just kind of like
it was almost like the final polish
point where I just wanted it to make
sure it looked really good and I was
really
I was having fun with it
and that's perfect that's that's all you
need
yeah and just wanted to to make this
look as
as good as I wanted it to look and I
think that the way I managed my time
early on gave me a bit of that buffer to
do so
that's that's perfect yeah I I think um
for me personally
uh you know I guess this kind of goes
back to all the stuff that I've been
thinking about since the beginning of
this year but uh
it's really hard to make stuff when
there's Stakes on uh or pressure is on
and
especially it's difficult to make stuff
that you think is good because you think
in your mind it needs to be the best
um quickly and that's just not realistic
and
um I think what you're doing here by
just diving in and having fun uh with no
real schedule or timeline there's no
pressure you you did a good job of
taking the pressure off and just having
fun and then once you
kind of
let your inspiration go and like
you've seen that you know there's
something here there's probably
something here uh then you can probably
get to like the schedule stuff later
um it seems like you got a real nice
healthy approach to this
um yeah so we have like five minutes
left that was the fastest gosh we do
ever
um so we can like do you wanna uh just
take it to q a here I'm sure everyone
has questions for you
um I'll I'll pop open the Cinema 4D file
just so it kind of plays in the
background yeah yeah yeah orbit around
that well
that's great yeah so guys please um at
Punisher in the chat here so I can oh we
got wind bush in the house
we got fried pixels what's up James
hey
yeah
all the all the good folks the bow graph
fam yeah exactly yeah
um James you going to NAB this year
you should
better
um
but uh yes we'll let these oh kenza's in
here too yes hey Kenza
that's great
that's great you got some support here
it's awesome man yeah
um hit me with them at punishers guys
ask some questions here we got another
we got like five minutes left four
minutes left
um so
uh James
see you next time though I'll see you
next time
oh mcdaffy's in here too I got some otoy
so good
um all right
why did I add the mouth and the
thumbnail oh that's a that's a good
question so yes I don't know if you
noticed I added a mouth to your rendered
I I did I I thought about giving you
crap about it but I was like yeah no
it's it's fine it's a thumbnail thing
it's like Clarity it's a Clarity thing
it's like um you'll read the face a
little bit more when uh sure yeah you
know when you see a face you know so I
added a big old cheesy anime smile to it
to like kind of yeah that's so funny
um it kind of has like a like a Calvin
and hob smile yeah for sure like yeah I
knew the people that knew especially you
you'd be like uh what did you do is that
important
yeah
YouTube marketing y'all
um let's see
how do you deal with management uh time
management and burnout
when you got CG as your day job
um and then you're trying to do CG for a
hobby like how does that work
it's a good question
that is a good question
um
I don't know if I have like the best
like time management tips or anything
like that
I mean the stuff that I do for my my day
job I really like too and there's lots
of opportunity to explore
for future projects at work for anyone
who doesn't know I work at Wyden Kennedy
on the the motion team there
um it's it's a great group and there's a
ton of Talent on there and we all we all
uh have different skills that we can
bring and share with each other and
I don't find myself ever feeling
I mean I can't say ever but like
I don't find myself super burned out
because the projects that I I get to
work on
in in my day job
uh also translate over to
translate into skills and techniques
that I can use for my personal passion
projects and so
I would say that I rarely feel burnt out
from doing personal work and day job
work on top of that that's great that's
great man keep that going for as long as
you can
um yeah because I would assume that in
your day job you get like different
projects coming in all the time so it's
always fresh I would assume right
yeah there's always something new to
learn especially for like the longer
term projects in there
um let's see we got time for like one
more uh
uh how long's your vendor take
how long the bread would take uh it took
about two to three hours actually really
um yeah and I actually just got one of
the new the new MacBooks so I was able
to put it through his Paces like the
week of render time and
you know it's not like a 40 90 level
graphics card but like it it's true to
the frames pretty quickly and also just
uh just a lot of optimizing so like a
lot of these are instances in the scene
and then I have grass in here that's
using it's using like a redshift proxy
object instead of just like a cloner or
hair and so that helped to render it a
lot quicker
um so yeah uh just a lot of
optimizing there brought it down to a
cool two to three hours render time
heck yeah dude that's incredible wow
yeah that's that's amazing
Um well hey man apologies we didn't get
through the whole the whole thing but
um that was a that was a very rich uh
uh beautiful overview of your scene
um I learned yeah I mean that was just
that whole time was inspiring for me
um but if you guys are at NAB this year
in Vegas go check out David milor he'll
be at the Maxon booth on Monday at 1 30.
that is the
17th this is the 17th yeah yeah April
17th uh in Vegas if you guys are annabi
go check them out I'm gonna make it
there
um so
yeah man I'll see you in Vegas in a
couple weeks yeah see you there buddy
thank you so much for uh for hopping in
and uh congrats again on the win man
it's super awesome and and thanks for
putting these these competitions on
they're a lot of fun absolutely man well
we'll talk uh we'll talk soon I'll see
you I'll see you at NAB yeah
yeah all right see ya peace out later
later
all right y'all
ah we got through two interviews so far
we got three more to go we're gonna do
third place uh is up next so we are
talking to well let's just find out I
think it's all queued up let's switch on
over
so do you wanna you wanna hit that
switch
it's gonna happen guys it's gonna happen
things are happening all right it's
brewing in the background I can hear
them they're working
oh snap Donald what's up man hello man
how are you
yeah pretty good pretty good excited a
little bit scared but oh don't worry
about it we're just gonna chat
um first things first can you pull up
your art for me can you just Loop it uh
for everybody kind of see
I hope it's smooth enough
autoplay
can you see it yeah it's uh
uh lagging a little bit but let's it
could just be Discord let me
oh let's open it like that looks
hilarious version yeah
yeah try to see if you can just Loop the
art
dude
I
this this render's so good
that's too good I should press repeat
yeah all good all good
um
how are you doing where are you from
so I live in Albania Central Europe
yeah it's
I don't know
it's evening here what else am I
supposed
I've never been to Albania
um maybe one day maybe one day I'll make
it out there it's near Italy near Italy
like between Italy and Greece I don't
know how to be more precise no no that's
perfect that's perfect that's all I need
to know
um dude how this is this is incredible
this art man like everything here is
ridiculous you're
first off your animation that you're
doing is absurd your render quality is
absurd this the idea itself is
ridiculous the the smoke Sims and the
Flames are ridiculous like I know this
was in the Ember gen release trailer
right so you use some Emergen
um yeah like you have a pilot getting
into the cockpit of that thing the the
way you warp out and distort the air in
the environment when the explosion goes
off it feels so good and you see those
missiles coming from the background
all the way from the top of the shot
like
dude uh how long have you been working
in 3D
so I started taking it seriously about
uh four years ago
yes
and I've been like doing it as a
professional job
I would say
in two years
okay the last two years what do you do
in four years completely focused in 3D
okay okay got you got you before those
four years were you like playing around
I was testing basically I might have
worked in 3D for like four months in
eight years entirely just okay playing
around for two weeks stopping and trying
again you know on and off wow man I
tried some Game Dev
mostly 2D stuff small games but it
didn't really go as planned it wasn't
didn't get viral you know
yeah yeah for sure for sure no this is
this is ridiculous for four years to be
honest like
this is
so good man
um what program are you using
some using blender yeah
exclusively like almost on all stages
like 2D and everything
okay awesome awesome how do you like
how do you even come up with this idea
you know what are you into what games
are you playing what movies are you
watching that that Inspire this kind of
art almost almost anything sci-fi really
okay so it's if it's creatures like the
thing is which people might find it a
bit weird after looking at other work of
myself like uh
basically sorry I need to mute something
just all good yeah all good all good
foreign no worries
okay can you hear me now
oh I can't hear you now
in Discord I can't hear you
yo yo yo test test
your okay but just there's an eco that I
don't know how to
how to fix really is it can you hear me
still
yep yep this is here perfectly okay cool
cool sweet
um is The Echoes one
yeah not really and I I'm not sure how
to fix it but it just makes it a bit
tough to to talk when you hear yourself
like a Nico you know yeah sort of
[Music]
I believe it's from the screen share
okay I might need to
yeah so
[Music]
oh turn off your camera right I think
turn off the camera sorry
oh you're good okay cool cool
you guys get the inner workings of the
stream here is that better
yep yep all right hey there you go Soto
crashing it yeah solving problems man
um
so I mean what like I I'm I'm seeing
like uh maybe some edge of tomorrow
maybe some uh what's that video game
with Ashley Burton I love that movie uh
yeah that one that one horizon zero down
yeah yeah that one yeah I believe yeah
yeah so I'm I'm seeing those two things
like uh
have you played those games is am I
right on the reference here or what else
do you have seen yeah I've seen the
movie absolutely love it I've tried the
game
the thing is like I'm I'm mostly I like
creature design a lot so that's the
thing I do at work oh cool
and here I'm just trying to to mix
like robots with creatures and that's
this is the end result basically that's
incredible so what do you do for work
how how like are you doing organic
creature design are you doing like
sculpting or organic designs I do both
the entire pipeline basically from from
2D sketch
3D scope rigging skinning and final
animation wow okay so you're you're
doing this all in 3D you're not doing
like uh like Miniatures like actual
Hands-On like miniature sculpting you're
doing 3D like zbrush
I I do it only all in blender everything
oh wow okay blend so I I I've actually
printed some of my sculptures some of my
designs yeah but mostly it's for games
and animation and movie
what got you into that what like
how did you find that path
well I I
I'm I remember the first Jurassic Park
from childhood and I think I just got
obsessed with Dinosaurs back then
I would play around with clay and
that kind of stuff you know watch the
movies over and over and documentaries
and
looking at a wildlife documentaries
and that's that's how it naturally I did
I realized that uh if I want to recreate
that kind of stuff I need to learn some
kind of 3D software
and that's how it happened basically it
was an old passion that gradually
converted into something else
that's that's wonderful man that sounds
organic and natural and uh
I don't know it's all it's all just kind
of like
I don't know being clarified for me that
when you're doing it for fun
and you don't really have an end goal
with it
and you just keep doing it for fun it
will really grow into something special
um
so that's really really cool to see so
walk us through here we got about
I don't know
20 minutes walk us through the the
process for this thing man like where
where do you start how do you create
so initially like the first moment I I I
heard there were the words engines when
you announce the the challenge yeah
I immediately want to do a running robot
and like try to mix my ability in
creature design with with robotics yeah
I had been already practicing if I can
share a quick screenshot
I had been practicing robot design
but never like managed to finish a
project
I see and I usually I used all the hype
and excitement from from The Challenge
to actually finish something oh that's
great yeah that's perfect
so this is like the first attempt
and I don't know if it's visible right
yeah yeah
so
I just
I need to put this on repeat
somehow how to play is
okay there you go so basically I just
got a free model of a lion running low
poly stuff just to get something quick a
quick idea so that I could in a sense
can you hear me right yeah yeah
okay perfect so the idea was to to get
this running robot I added a pilot and
some low quality quick stuff initially
the the scene was going to be in
in the desert yeah
so this is pretty simple you know just
to get a feeling of does it actually
look cool does it have potential yes or
no that that was all yeah and I felt
confident that I could actually pull
something something out of this
something interesting amazing that kind
of stuff it gradually evolved I I added
the scenery
with rocks and cliffs this is still an
early stage before I decided to
completely shift the the design of the
world
so yeah initially the creature was going
to the robot actually was going to jump
from the cliff transform
so it was a completely different theme
was going to be made like out of scrap
Parts as if the the pilot designed
something in their garage with with
whatever they could find yeah
but later I felt like maybe I need to
add a little bit more drama and
excitement
and I decided to go for a battle scene
oh a battle dude that's a
uh it's very am there's a huge change
yep
so this is where like everything changed
actually
it did a like very quick animation of a
dog or cheetah at least I took
inspiration from those creatures
Capital low poly
placed here the the enemy ship
and the like the main ship the main
platform yeah whole idea was that our
our main characters were being attacked
and there were only a few seconds to
escape and then survive the final
explosions
with the trails of the rockets and
they're like they had this effect of a
loading screen that you know something
is about to happen you know you can see
it in the distance yeah it's being
filled until they they and with the hope
of of feeling the viewer with excitement
so something is about to happen we just
have to wait for the Rockets to to reach
the target that's perfect this was the
main idea with the composition with the
curvature and everything
it's already such a great
idea
and you're doing such a good job of
blocking it out in a very simple way to
prove that there's some that works yeah
exactly
so here I I started experimenting with
with volumetrics and fires I haven't
hadn't really done this before like I
got a bit
surprised when it got featured into the
amberjan trailer
because it's like my first time playing
with fire
pun intended but the like fire and smoke
and and
this kind of stuff this is crazy this is
like we're seeing this come to life
before our eyes this is so crazy
everything's getting a little bit better
with each iteration
all right so We're looping version 10
now okay
wow so you have your your smoke Sims in
you have your main ship pretty modeled
in you have your background trip pretty
modeled in you have the character itself
uh the character looks pretty complete
the robot itself is still like there's
more details finished yeah yeah
absolutely so I kept the shell until the
very early later stages because I wanted
to make sure I got the silhouette right
it was bulky enough and strong enough
until I I decided to add the final
details
and are you like modeling all this stuff
um or are these assets or what no this
is like the only asses that I used here
that were not mine where the the clouds
background yeah the human topology the
main topology with a very generic human
rig that you get from blender
and I believe somewhere here is like one
of your scratch imperfect imperfection
textures that I got for free I don't
know two years ago was it yeah I don't
remember correctly that's funny so it's
somewhere in here everything else is is
like my assets basically wow designed
some of them for Scratch for this
project and I also recycled a robot that
I designed for I believe your second
ever 3D challenge
oh three parts from the robot and uh
like I feel the the empty space is in in
the ship and the enemy ship and that
kind of stuff I did recycle you know
that's good they are all my assets no
that's good that's good that just goes
back to the point where I was saying um
with Sam like you know
you never know what's gonna happen as
long as you keep working on your on your
craft on your passion
you're Paving the way for your future
self so you're going to have so much
more to work with if you just you know
stick with it
um but what gave you the idea for this
guy in the background because that is so
scary to me dude no no this is this was
a surprise to me too because the initial
idea basically I was going to feel the
anger with a replicas of the running
robot okay to give a more dramatic uh
look and I would add Pilots trying to
get into the their cabins to escape
burning in the fire and the Heat and
everything
but uh I just put the robot that I used
in your second challenge I placed it
there as a placeholder and what happened
is there was not enough time to to
actually change it and update it
so
jumping right like to a more advanced
version so I just left it there I had no
idea actually I forgot about it that it
had that menacing look you know and I
just realized it during the stream where
you guys were saying like look at the
bad guy in the background like oh
looking all menacing and everything oh
dude like it was a surprise oh yeah I
left him there and it was unexpected for
me too wow that's I love it man so there
was no story behind that really it
wasn't a happy accident I I would say
wow I would say so too that is crazy
yeah like that's
that there's so much going on with that
guy he's like he caused all of this and
he doesn't care like this thing is
blowing he's like the T the T-1000 he's
like nothing's gonna stop get out of the
fire yet oh dude that is too cool so are
you flipping it to just try and see
what's missing
at this stage I flipped it to to get a
better feeling like of the composition
and basically like scaling up and down
certain parts of the scene to see how
they fit how to make them look better I
believe I increased the scale of the
wing of our
perspective like a fresh eye hmm
yeah it's it's super helpful you you
switch back and forth and because
sometimes you get too used to what what
you're looking at
and it uh you started to to not pay
attention to to mistakes or certain lost
details that's a good one man I I it's
an old trick but I never use it and um
it's probably one of the best and
easiest ways to get a different
perspective like we were talking about
you know early earlier
um you know trying to see your your art
from a different perspective and uh
going to going to take a break coming
back the next day and you're going to be
a different artist than you were the day
before so you're gonna have a new look
at it the next day that you would but
flipping it like this is a great way to
kind of get out of the headspace you've
been in forever and uh it's very easy to
do and it like kind of seems like a
no-brainer but yeah I need to utilize
this one more so for the animation like
are you hand animating this dude did you
rig it and then you hand animate the rig
or everything everything like it's from
scratch basically I created a basic rig
I don't know if I could open here right
now
an early stage of the rig
sweet
so this was a low poly version with
simple shapes is it visible yeah yeah
just checking okay and I animated it I
used some like references in YouTube I
there were some short videos of dogs
running and cheetahs and get a feeling
of Speed and Agility and flexibility of
the body
so it's all like a quick rig
it's mirrored so there is no actual
realism in the sense of the the the one
two three four times before yeah yep
exactly exactly that I I did that only
in the last couple of days I believe I
kept the mirror animation just so that I
could get a very quick result as as soon
as possible you know
oh man I know nothing about animation
this is already like really impressive
this would take me so long to do
it's very different from from modeling
actually it took me some time to
actually get used of of wrapping my head
around
the techniques and understanding timing
and weight that kind of stuff yeah for
sure
but once you get used it's pretty fun
so we have about
we have about what eight minutes left so
we'll take it to the chat here oh oh
what up EJ we got Eye Design up in here
uh
we'll take it to the chat if you guys
have any questions for Donald hit me
with the at Punisher I'll check this in
a minute while Donald continues through
his versions here
foreign
basically these are really close to the
days of work oh every day I would I
would do a quick render I render a Navy
which is pretty fast it's like
what it's supposed to be the real time
render engine of blender yeah yeah
so it doesn't take that much to get a
daily render that you can look in your
free time and try to pick details where
to add and where to remove stuff that's
a cool idea I like that doing a render
each day and seeing it's a good good
half of the box too yeah yeah
yeah
so I started adding more details to
Breeze I simulated this in ceiling
blender but on another file project to
keep things light yes and re-imported it
in in the main file as an Olympic
yes so and started adding layers of
simulation from amberjen
oh it's starting to look starting to
come together here yeah more and more
than explosion still the trails of the
of the Rockets here are like 3D meshes
with weird textures so I added the final
simulations in the last couple of days I
believe
so you're do this was the first time you
used amberjet
this is the second time the first time I
used it on I believe one year and a half
ago yeah and then I paused and I had to
relearn a few things you know you get a
subscription and you play around you use
the presets because you always want to
start with something quick and you play
around with the presets and tweak them
and try to get something pleasant hmm
but there's a lot of like fake imagery
here or effects manual effects on the
smoke like for example the shadow I
don't know if if it's visible the smoke
Trail here yeah the shadow is hand
painted it's so the scene the smokes are
only like plates they're not really in
the scene in the sense I see they do not
get the lighting yes I had to fake that
and
I have another effect in a later
render I'm opening the final render
because there isn't much
of a change here oh man it's so good
so even the fire here gets brighter
because of the explosion the smoke sorry
yeah it gets brighter that was all like
I rendered the smoke twice with
different lights and I switched
transitioned cool between them to give
the effect of actually being some kind
of a lighting effect I love it I love it
ah so good so so much detail let's see
what the chat has uh
they want to know they want to know how
old you are for some reason
so I'm 31. I'm 31. oh wow okay cool okay
an idea
um
uh Felipe says how did you approach the
modeling for the main character for the
for this robot
so I I've been practicing for like a few
years like in the background I never
published robots but I constantly I'm
trying to to
learn how to design them
and like I'm constantly practicing and
the idea was very simple here I I
initially wanted to get a certain
silhouette with certain feeling of of
strength and
speed so I got the silhouette first and
only later I decided to use the kid
bashing technique with my own models to
to fill in the gaps to give it a feeling
of complexity yeah
so wow okay this was do something simple
first and then you add more and more
without breaking the initial idea that's
a great man you got your workflow down
that's awesome
um
another question here was how often you
practice 3D
daily like I'm all my almost all my free
time is spent experimenting with stuff
that I'm not good at yeah yeah so like
after I put a few hours of work on my
like professional projects I go and try
some new stuff in blender
that's amazing because it's daily always
practicing that's great
that's good advice
um let's see any other questions we got
three more minutes okay we got time for
some questions uh yeah the
transformation how how difficult was it
to do that transformation there was it
pretty straightforward or what
so the idea with the transformation I
initially it was going to be even more
animal looking the wings were going to
were supposed to be like birds wings
but later that was a bit too tough to
rig and actually get the shape right so
I simplified it
and of course it's not perfect but the
main point was to make it to make the
creature robot look like as if it was
trying to become aerodynamic so yeah I
decided to fold the hands and the feet
and also added some shapes on top to
make it look curved like it could
actually pierce the air easily that was
like the main idea yeah and you know
push a piece a little bit more on the
left a little bit higher so that it can
fit you know just try to mesh them
together without breaking anything oh
it's beautiful it's a very seamless
transition and it's not like it's not
like you're going from a
you know from like a it doesn't feel
like a Transformers transformation it
feels different you know I try to stay
away from from like
those kind of existing IPS yeah to have
my own thing you know and it feels that
way that's good
um let's see uh was it one render one
final render or did you have like pieces
did you like follow match volumetrics
separate and then combine it together
and post
almost everything is one render the only
thing that I had to render on a
different layer where the smoke Trails
for the Rockets yes because like blender
with this real-time render engine that I
use uses layers so what happens if you
expand the rendering of the volumetrics
a bit too far you get to see a certain
flickering so okay save time I rendered
them separately with a higher resolution
and then compose that on top I see
that's smart very smart
um last question people are wondering uh
I have your Instagram in the description
here I have all the artists for anyone
wondering of all the artists info in the
description but they're wondering if you
specifically have an art station page or
is Instagram the best place
well I actually have it all like YouTube
Instagram I in Instagram I put more like
whip work in progress progress stuff but
on our station I have more detailed and
behind the scenes and some sketches and
ideas like how how I approach certain
elements and also a YouTube channel oh
man you got it all okay yeah please
um type it here in our in our group chat
right here and then I'll copy paste that
into the into the live chat
um and uh
or you know what just type it into the
live chat people will get it if you type
it into the live chat once we once we
head out here
um that way people can follow you and
I'll be sure to add it to
um the description as well but Donald
man thank you so much we we were blown
away by your art myself Ren uh Peter and
the captain so uh such a pleasure yeah
dude yeah killing it man please continue
uh your work I know you will you know
you're very dedicated and very
passionate so I cannot wait to see more
from you and maybe we'll work together
in the future who knows man like
really really cool stuff super excited
thank you thank you absolutely
absolutely all right we'll catch you
soon man peace out thank you so much
yeah
oh boy hello
oh wait where are we back to Donald hold
on
what's happening Soto
[Laughter]
oh man
what's up how do we pronounce your name
here
so okay what what's the name you got on
the screen Monas
yeah pretty close limonus like is it
limonis or limonus
the second one was the praise one
luminous
yes sir I know okay now I have many
names but that's the one sweet yeah you
know uh Leo P whatever you want sir you
go
sweet yeah
welcome Lee lymanus welcome
um dude your your art I gotta say is
probably the most unique out of all the
renders that I saw
um this is ridiculous like I don't know
what
I don't know where you're hanging out to
put this together like this is crazy man
wow what a piece of art congratulations
I really appreciate it I mean that was
my goal so I guess I achieved it a bit
of a confusion a bit of a
sort of making it nice and jelly-like
but mostly yeah yeah the dealer yeah
yeah so where where are you from
uh so I'm based in the UK but you know
I'm Lithuanian that's why I'm born but I
live in the UK now
sweet and how long you've been working
in 3D
let me look at mine I'd say I'd say a
bit of it over 10 years
wow okay yeah it shows man
um I had I had quite a journey I started
with Cinema 4D uh and then
professionally I did Maya for three or
four years and then I got back into
Cinema 4D after it became kind of hot
stuff again so yeah
yeah I had a similar similar experience
I started in r10 actually and then
switched to 3ds Max for six years and
Maya for like three months and then uh
back to c4d runic when it got hot again
yeah exactly nice nice That's right
um um I'm hoping to move on to blender
of course I don't know
that's all it's all Journey you know
whatever gets you inspired so it doesn't
really matter what program you're using
it's just the art that comes from it I
think
yeah I think we all know that at this
point but um yeah
I feel like I say that all the time I
see the chats always on blender nation
and all this and it's like I mean you
guys don't really do that but
I I think uh go go you know go blend the
nation why not you know yeah absolutely
whatever whatever makes you happy
honestly if even if you make everything
like Microsoft Paint well I'll support
that that's pretty cool yeah yeah you
never know where people are at on their
journey and what what they need to to do
to make their best start it could you
know it's so subjective and um it
doesn't make sense to like shame anybody
for using a certain software just feels
very strange like you gotta get the
DeWalt tools you know like you gotta
it's like who cares they're it's a it's
a drill you know
um tell about a Milwaukee man Milwaukee
but I'm a DeWalt guy friend sure I'm not
gonna lie oh um
that's funny uh yeah
what can we talk about
yeah yeah so you said you started out
like how did you get started um you said
you've been in for 10 years what was the
thing that like was like I'm gonna do 3D
right
um so early days it was Photoshop I was
making giant giant gifts
full HD GIFs and at some point I
um
let's see I was going to introduce to
editing I think Sony Vegas at a time
yeah uh and then after Ferguson premium
Adobe stuff
and then my uh
and then eventually Cinema 4D again and
here here I am
sweet so it's just a creative outlet for
you then um that's cool yep yep
let's get into this art man where do you
even begin with this thing
cool uh should I pop over to my um
My Scene yeah whatever you got okay so I
know some people
so I know we're thinking
um how do they simulate this and there's
there's pretty much no simulation in
this at all
um great in fact most of the stuff and
this is the top saying some like uh you
know actual like simulation guys like
TDS will tell you if you can avoid
simulation then don't simulate oh okay
and that's that's always my go-to so
actually all I got is um
you can see here I've got three
displaces
with some good old
okay there's my little vertex Maps yes
yes okay you can imagine I got one
displacer here that does
the base space waves and all it is is a
noise
oh yeah
just just going and uh
X Direction I think yeah okay that's so
smart
oh and it's you know it's pretty pretty
Speedy as well
so it kind of helps
yeah just uh cheat it and from from the
very start I had a goal of having as
many flaps as I can yeah and so I got my
main flaps I got some side flaps there's
some top flaps and I got a little
uh backflips
they all they all got their own bit of
displacements you know each each unique
strength and and that's all that's so
cool that's so cool did you like utilize
this technique is this like your your
um biggest
like culmination of this technique or
were you doing this in like other
projects in a small way or
uh yeah 100 okay
um well one thing that happens all the
time is you do a simulation and then
you're thinking oh I'm gonna have to let
some data let's do a tweak and it never
works out because simulation is fickle
it's very fickle yeah yeah and so over
time I've learned to simplify as much as
I can and this place is just such a
beautiful tool uh just does a
bake everything bake everything
so okay yeah so I've done
looks like there's a jingle but there's
also a cloth sorry I'm not the best
prepared
because
um I was actually I didn't use this as
an opportunity to learn in Cinema's new
uh you know cloth tools and stuff it's
pretty cool yeah it's cool yes there's
also some extra socks
um
so so it is cloth but very very rigid uh
basically it's just fully
oh actually it's a cinema 25 I made this
in 2023 knock um so basically you know
the mix animation uh option they're
getting cloth
uh which basically pretty much pulls the
shape with some Dynamics happening on
top yeah uh so that's what that's what
I've done for the sax
um so yeah how do you get them to
connect like how are they connected
so I think the way they work actually
um
again
they are
let me just find which doesn't suck
so this little little taste the sack
over here
um basically another text map another
fantastic tool yeah uh what it does is
um
this the the red areas it comes in
inverted the red area is 100 to follow
the animation which is staying with the
body and then everything further down is
slightly eases off and gets a bit more
wind until it's happening um ah it's
wonderful
so so really
on the rig so if I jiggle this rig a
little bit uh what you notice is that
this is how close they stay with the rig
I see yes
you know um and then from there a bit
um a bit of cloth happening on top yeah
okay
um
yeah yes that's that's the the stash is
fully
let me find my level
so I've actually I've actually made two
versions of the rig
uh so my little stash is actually
uh full full soft body cloth simulation
so you can see as we can see here that
they do quite nice
sort of
well affected by the wind and as the
mouth opens all that fun stuff
[Music]
yep so so they are they are fully
fully soft soft body slash cloth
with a similar technique is the sex uh
fully follow here and then loose loose
yeah as it goes along and they are baked
down you said right
always always back down yeah they've got
to be out here somewhere for this for
this example I want to make but you can
see it's intersecting
um
that's hard to tell though yeah
um so what about the I love it
um I want to get into references in a
minute here but let's figure let's let's
finish up the like Dynamic stuff so you
have the little antennas on top you have
the little
um like car wash stuff on the bottom and
then you have the seaweed on the back so
those three
yes so seaweed again exactly as the body
yes
um it's instead actually of a displacer
I went and even lighter way because I
didn't optimize my jumpsuit too well if
you look at them okay yeah uh so
basically
okay they are baked but basically the
tail flaps
uh use just a plane
so playing in a deformer mode
um and this is this is the lightest way
possible in cinema to like deform stuff
you mean like they're they're parent
like they're parented to uh like
actually like the ffd thing where it's
like a low poly they follow the low poly
uh reference
uh nope this this heavy this heavy thing
is deformed as you see there
geez
yeah it says so it's definitely a
chungus in in that but but basically my
little
uh plane because all they do is move
points up
you know it's it's very simple it
doesn't take look at normals or anything
really
um
it's just these fields going through
them and it looks it kind of does does
the job oh you're talking fields and I
see I see I see okay that's like
without the fields all it does this
affect us simply takes all the points
and moves them up
and back a little bit
I see in the fields there's like that's
where you're getting the waves from
that's right the different chunks of it
happening at different times and the is
the vertex map keeping it locked down
like the the connecting points
uh nope uh what you'll see here if you
look at my Fields yeah uh what the two
orange boxes
yes uh yes
so so okay so this guy actually like
limits the effects of the plane yeah
just after
the points where it's attached
they're very simple uh the quickest
method I could find without you know
retoping these even more and keeping the
maps that's very smart um
amazing yeah
it's a lot of a lot of a lot of baking
all right what about the the car wash
down there
the car wash oh so this guy uses my my
absolute favorite thing in cinema which
is a spline deformer and everyone's uses
it always
forever because um so basically it's uh
a load of hair
um currently it's got Dynamic stuff
yeah let's see what happens it's gonna
do some really wacky stuff basically
again you put on a little bit of wind
and it kind of goes back it looks like
it's moving forward
and also
follows the rig really well
and then all you do with this with this
hair which is really light take take a
capsule
as they say you know and it's being like
the movement is coming from what
uh from from the from the hair
it's just uh really basic hair that
you're using hair okay
yeah the hair is another really
wonderful
um
you know you just put on a bit of wind
blow it away and it looks like it's uh
so innocent you're very well-rounded in
c4d like you're hitting all these all
these things that I rarely never I never
use is
a wacky way uh be creative you know be
creative how you use this yeah
um and in fact these little guys
these are they're FK uh or ik and also
these are these are ik so these are not
these are not at all simulated
all I have is uh if you know cappuccinos
called the cappuccino
uh I just did this I
guess yeah that was that yeah oh so you
live recorded that movement yeah is what
you're saying yeah
and you're doing that with um with how
uh so
if you if you know a regular regular old
sorry I'll solo that I know how much how
we're doing on time but it's really up
to you we have 15 minutes
cool it's a regular it's a regular sort
of chain of joints yes in an ik and
you've got one controller
and with a simple bind it just attaches
to my little
uh actual Geo and you can do your thing
and then remember you said you're alive
you were live animating it though like
you hit play and you moved that up
or you just put noise on it
no no I did I did animator I did
animated by hand um so I did say low
damage and everything
and all I did was press cappuccino which
yeah records at real time and all that
was this
just exactly okay that's what cappuccino
is okay that's cool yes sorry uh it's
just it's yeah it records your sort of
uh Mouse movements yeah that's great
it's really it's pretty good for this
like random motion um you know I tried
dynamics of this but it wasn't working
and instead of just trying to get it
right I just went
like this and that was that was it
that's perfect dude so like wow this is
like a wonderful presentation this is so
good uh okay so
I have questions on the idea how the
heck
did you come up with this like concept
uh Tricky Tricky Tricky uh let me go
to the pure ref
um
so I uh for this for this one project I
went slightly
different than I normally would which is
like quite a lot of planning I kind of
went
um
just I I had like a few a few sort of
to-do's I knew I want to do a jiggly
creature that's quite like Pleasant a
bit cute
uh not not to not too gross yeah a bit a
bit wet and Lively there's a lot of sex
uh and then from there it kind of just
evolved
um
so if you look over here I do mostly
have horror references
um
the one of my favorite ones was
these little crab creatures uh so
initially I was going to have quite like
DD
freaky eyes this time it's a dream whoa
yes
um and so so my first thing to do was
go on Art Stage Station and type in uh
Richard with sex
uh and it was there was actually I think
this this is the closest reference I
could find
this this guy's that's me uh that's
really good
yes that's great that's great man
it's just a tastiness isn't it and it's
it's wet it's Lively it's got some fuzz
on it yeah that's the closest I've come
to wanting to eat a bug is is right now
looking at that image
yeah
uh let's see
uh so so initially I was going to have
these sort of antennas with some ions in
them eyes sorry a bit like a crustacean
I guess
um but after a bit of time
I've I've realized I want to do you know
this yeah yeah and can't go wrong
and uh she was always there I was there
supporting you know that's perfect and a
perfect indeed uh yeah
so lots of live references from there
and I kind of I kind of generally I I
built this up as I go
so it might have started out with with
one of these like sacky creatures and
then I kind of build up as I go and I'd
create a little new section of just eyes
because I knew the eyes are going to be
quite big and many pixels in the frame
base so it's been a lot of time looking
at them
so yeah get your refs very good
um some environments
um
I would I would say these are these are
quite AI inspired that's one thing AI
does well in my opinion is these yeah
concept art stuff
yeah these interestingly these weren't
there's one made by Me by the way these
are some other artists but it's you know
the look you can know the look of my
journey early days and that's kind of a
and so so it was
very nice
yeah kitty cats and they have my very
short to-do list
um I knew I knew I wanted some basic
things uh of character interacting with
the environment
you know for example hitting something
or like dodging something yeah just for
Just For Better integration
um and the
that can be seen actually early on in
the video
when it flies through this field of
uh jiggly jiggly tubes
that's kind of I was kind of it at the
start and then I evolved into having a
purpose which is chasing my little
glowy
creatures yes sure the plumbuses I I
know they are essentially plumbuses
a lot of a lot of Rick and Morty went
into this
um how did you how did you do the eye
like what yeah is that after effects or
something
so that that's a lot of pumping uh but
let me go let me go over the eye model
so here's my little which is
yeah you actually don't see this too
much but it does have um well very early
on in the video it has this protective
like a layer opener yes you can see that
yep it's kind of
you know I know we're done let's kind of
spend time for it to be visible for only
five frames or so uh but yeah his uh
here's the eye
all it has
a blend shape
whoa
kind of
um and one thing
that not many artists do is actually
sculpt and bake stuff in cinema
let me just take a look
I got my a big size
um because it's actually it's
surprisingly good at um
it's not gonna do a great job
but um
it's not good it's not quite shiny um
basically uh you can you can do really
high details called let's say three
million polies and then bake it all into
a mesh as like this you know it's quite
usable and
uh all the other Maps kind of remain
there which is really a lot of fun I do
all the time without without ever going
to zbrush yeah I I do recommend it
uh are you like maxing out this program
it's awesome I I did it to the limit
when they had editing and compositing
then I'm definitely I'm gonna be
sticking with it but yeah I have that uh
yeah so so was there was there much
compositing uh in editing
uh yes yes indeed
uh so actually one other thing I
utilized they don't see too often is the
old
UV pass there you go material UV okay so
you're isolating each
material as it comes out as its own
color
yes and I can I can show this guy to you
uh whoa so that's what it looks like
when you that's your raw render
this is my raw render but I think this
is it's pretty close and uh it's it's
got the um
because I'm working in uh what's called
Aces uh yes it does have the color color
conversion applied in this PNG
basically once you restack your
sorry if I just try it once you restack
your exr so as you know layer dxr
uh you get something like a bit like a
log so here you go that's more like it
and then and then you've got to convert
it back to that
using these funky little open color IO
stuff
yes yeah it's a bit of a pain but I
think I think uh a new After Effects uh
so all of your atmosphere and water that
underwater look is coming from After
Effects
uh yes also another thing fun fact
it's it's supposed to be more of a zero
gravity situation yeah yeah yeah it's
not necessarily water I got you yeah
yeah because I did look at some
reference of underwater stuff and
actually there's there's no specular
underwater fun fact it doesn't really
need the specular oh yeah uh so
basically if
my eyes are post
uh wow
the way the way this thing works is I
have
I can hear your computer revving up
right now is that your computer fan I
hear that's my laptop it's yeah
uh yes so it's basically of
made this little comparoni here let me
yeah basically this is this is what
happens
oh cool so it's just like a bunch of
like colored uh action Essentials man
yeah the best
the best absolutely and it's got some
time remap and a little
like a lens thing I didn't actually have
to do this but basically afterwards it
goes on
to this
disable that sorry it's like dude you
need to tour the world with this
workflow man this is ridiculous
so this is uh this is a UV map and what
it means lets you do as you know back
any texture back on top
um and so so I did
um let me just come back a little bit
there they go so first of all you mat it
out
and plug in that wrap stuff around
uh and then boink whatever it is
how does it track on
yeah
this is this is the magic of these Maps
uh I believe the the way they work
is if you look at green this is
coordinate something and red is called
in a something else
and it knows to take whatever you give
it and wrap it on these Corners it's
kind of magic I can't really explain it
but I know how it was it just tracks
automatically
uh yes yes so what the heck
you go you gotta look into these so if
you look
everything gets this
applied yeah um it gets it honestly
because
my map uh was made by the eyes it
doesn't look there's anything else but
you can put
text or anything you want on there so if
I
walk this for a moment I had a little
reference guy
for my centering
well it's not there anymore
yeah yeah
wow yeah so you can put anything you
want in post and of course if you have
your full render passes you can put it
under Reflections and specular so
it sits perfectly back in dude this is
insane
yeah man comp 100
uh and I can
also show my
depth stuff actually I hope it's not
broken
okay so I think
there it is okay so this is
I think this might be the final come
okay
okay yes uh so this looks looks pretty
good
pretty good to what I expect to look
like
and it's a lot of depth passes
doing doing a lot of it wow
um
and also I have
so one other thing I forgot to mention
actually at a cinema I would export the
camera and a load of nulls
yes
and then basically you just put your
smoke cards in here
and they just kind of do their thing
yeah well that's great because yeah I
know I know blender does this really
well just for free in viewport and
whatnot um uh ratchet is not that good
at handling
sort of semi-transparent object with
that yeah so keep it for post
dude that that's ridiculous that uh
that that is actually absolutely absurd
I feel like we could do this for another
30 minutes easily
um
okay
that's basically our time I mean we've
got like two more minutes I I don't know
like
I'm Blown Away questions uh I appreciate
it one one thing that's very hard to
learn is when to stop the CG
and go I've got to render and do the
rest and post
post I guess yeah yeah I mean so you're
you know do you still have trouble with
that being you know this part of your
career
I I definitely do it's kind of
surprising
um
you know get a sort of close but I gotta
trust myself
that I can you know I can take this kind
of like
a rough background and turn it into
something quite like nice in post you
know yeah yeah exactly exactly exactly
well it's just smart I think it's really
smart because you're probably helping
yourself with render times and you're
probably giving yourself the most I love
it you're probably giving yourself the
most uh flexibility in post it's just
you got a really smart workflow I'm
blown away by this workflow and and your
your knowledge of all the different
aspects of both C40 and after effects
that is
you're on another level here man
I do I do appreciate it yeah um guys we
have like a minute left if you have I
mean we got time for like one question
um
let's see don't get don't get me started
on my uh Little Creature setup they are
also simulation free
oh wow
my little Columbus's that's right no
Sims no Sims over here that's so good
man I'm Blown Away seriously I I think
guys I think that's time I think we need
to move on but uh
jeez man I
I'm speechless thank you for that I I'm
gonna go back and watch that and I'm
gonna be in contact for sure
man that that is that is incredible
thank you thank you so much for your
time what are you gonna do with this
afterwards like are you gonna do more
stuff in this style or are you just
moving on
uh I would I would love to I would love
to I've got many ideas but not that much
time yeah yeah I'll just have to see
just have to see where it goes
but uh awesome man
sweet all right uh let me see like
limous limous that's right that's right
yeah
yeah but thank you brother have a good
one we'll see you soon all right thank
you for your time man congratulations
peace out man peace
hey
Breezy hi Clinton do you hear me I do I
do yes do you hear me yeah awesome yes
perfectly Yes Man
oh so happy to hear yeah yeah absolutely
did you catch that last uh that last
chat with Lee or yeah that was crazy
yeah I I was watching all of them that's
great great stuff yeah absolutely man
um so you you come from Rio de Janeiro
all the way from Brazil yeah
yeah exactly uh actually I live in a
closed city called niteroi okay it is
very very close to Rio De Janeiro but I
usually say Regional because Ever Knows
everybody knows who yeah yeah for sure
um that's cool man so we're yeah we're
flying you out uh to Colorado a new
campograph yeah this year that's gonna
be sweet I can't wait yeah it's gonna be
awesome man congrats congrats on first
place
um yeah which is incredible like you you
had actually a really close version of
the scene within week one or two I'd say
two
is that right or uh yeah uh well uh not
that close
uh I I think uh things ran really smooth
uh more than I anticipated thankfully
yeah uh but yeah I have a a very
Advanced uh
um step in week two
uh the week three was basically to
create the Chaser bug yeah on the back
and make extra
uh set dressing and color grading stuff
okay got you got you I mean you had I
guess what I mean by you got pretty far
in the beginning was you had this guy
animated like this pretty soon
um I'm blown away at everything
involving this one the lighting the idea
the animation the design of the
characters the color the render quality
um even the camera shake the like
everything is perfect
um where
all right
where do you start with something like
this like
where are you connecting these ideas
from first off
uh I was lucky uh because I I
got aware of this Challenge on the day
one yeah and I watched your announcement
on day one and before finishing to watch
the announcement I already came with an
idea
uh that was the first thing I thought
the first thing I thought uh well uh
mechanical insects are cool so how do I
work with this and then I remembered uh
uh uh I remember a movie that I lost
when I was a kid called uh kids I shrink
sorry honey I shrink the kids yes
yeah and yeah there is a scene that the
kids uh was riding a giant ant to cross
the garden so I kept that in my mind and
funny thing is uh I didn't took
reference for the movie I just I just
kept in my mind and tried to work on it
yeah okay okay so you didn't go back to
it and try and like copy it or anything
you just remember yeah yes yes
that's cool so you didn't I like that
because
you know your idea of it might be
different than the actual
you know the actual movie you know it
might have shifted in your mind it might
be it might be cooler in your mind
actually
um yeah uh it's a smart idea to like not
go back and just remember
yeah and actually uh I did this uh for
the whole process uh of course I use
references I I took a bunch of
references uh actually I took the first
weekend just thinking about it and
taking reference from it but I didn't
want to go too crazy with too much
reference and options so I I want to
make something fresh from my mind as
well and this was a very good exercise
and uh I did this for all another
previous work as well I I took some
previous work as reference but I didn't
check the reference itself I just kept
in my mind and trying to make a new
thing not copying it but just remember
having the working with the memory I
have from this previous works I like
that a lot that's that's actually great
because
it is nice to have reference but at the
same time we couldn't get locked too too
locked in you know um
you know uh like the since the beginning
of this year I've really been doing a
lot of focus on creativity and like
where it comes from and all this and
um one of one of the things I read I
mean shout outs real quick
because this book is incredible uh the
Rick Rubin book right here I don't know
if you guys have seen this maybe you
have heard of it but it's called the
creative act and uh it it talks about
how like it has a chapter on rules and
how if you have too many rules at the
beginning
um too many barriers then you really
pigeonhole yourself into this
only only one or two things can happen
when you're within this like you have so
many rules but if you take away all the
rules all the labels and you just give
yourself as many options as possible you
can really find some cool stuff so I've
never heard of that I've always known as
references just being something I always
go back to I always go back to but to
hear you say that
you gathered it at the beginning and you
just studied it and internalized it and
then you moved on that's all you need
yeah and you can kind of break free from
the reference in that sense but while
still having an idea of it that's so
cool
yeah uh it is crucial having reference
but uh throughout the years working with
this uh you gather so much reference and
a lot of them uh get stuck to your head
and it is nice to visit it that peace of
mind and try to access over there and
things start getting a little abstracts
and you can create new stuff from this
yeah I love it I love it it's great
um so you gathered some reference you
internalized it what's your next move
what do you do
uh so uh I start blocking out uh I'm not
a good drawer
so I started make a simple blocking in
blender
uh that's even cool I like that that's
fun
a very very simple blocking uh nothing
fancy I wasn't worried with the topology
nothing like that are just basic shapes
yeah
um but I need to see if it works of
course in the in the angle camera angle
and that's great that you provide this
uh because it is so helpful uh because
when you first open a 3D software uh it
is kind of overwhelming because you just
see a blinks a a blank viewport yeah
there's nothing there and think oh
anything can happen here and when you
when you have a template like this it is
great it is a huge shortcut yeah uh
it's kind of the opposite of what you're
just talking about where like there's
too many there's not enough rules we
need one or two rules maybe like to get
us you know limitations can be nice in a
way and um it kind of sets the playing
field just a bit so I see what you're
saying yeah
yeah definitely uh so I made this very
simple blockout and uh linked
to this
um the vehicle in and out that you
provided yeah and just let it go but
watch this for a few days
and then started moving forward with a
more uh complex blockout and uh one nice
thing that I think about blender is the
use of Grease pencil so since since I'm
not a drawer uh sometimes I go sketch on
my block out
um like
and they put the surface and sets
the offsets
and just draw simple shapes here where
I'm going to cut make more details
over here
uh let's do a heart here maybe some
fancy face
um and you can continue working on top
of this
um yeah and yeah that's the first step
uh I started I I made I go further with
the blocking out
let me hear I did actually this is the
latest model
um well uh blackout blackout is the key
since I I can't sketch anything like
that I I have um
I can understand a little better what
I'm doing with very simple shapes yeah
and a lot of people uh keep asking oh
man how do you how do mother complex
stuff like this well you always have to
start simple
simple shapes and start to cut it and
then you add subdivision add extra Loops
to hold that edges to make it sharper
and things start and
things start to flow yeah from this
point
and just starts to float uh and in the
middle of the process I made a a simple
rig that is nothing very complex
um
a bunch of
eye case bones
and I I did this this rig before
finishing the model uh because one thing
that I like to do a lot of stuff I like
to model I like to shading I like to
animate uh composite lighting uh and I
wanted to do all at once
and I don't want to spend any time in um
in something that won't be imported but
will be unnoticed yeah uh so a good work
a good way that works well for me is
working all at once so I start blocking
it make the rig make the animation
continuing modeling
and what I did here was
um I this is the the rig of the the
character
and there is this point here
that is uh it has a constraint that
follows the surface of the floor so cool
it continues conforming on it so yeah I
can continue animating I don't I I
wasn't worried of the realistic
side of things I didn't want to make
anything looks real I like this stylish
look
and
so the legs doesn't
follow the ground very well uh yeah yeah
this book slides like we were wondering
we were wondering that I think it was
MDK he was like one of the modders he's
like I wonder if the legs actually
because he's very technical right and
he's wondering if the legs match the
ground and I was like I wonder too so
you're just you're just doing you're
just doing this and it just works
because yeah it does it yeah I I did a
loop because uh this is very forgiving
because uh I did a quick animation of
each leg uh this synchronized them so we
make this cycle uh let me turn off the
constraints here because I
I like to work on the
Road origin so yeah adding this cons I I
linked
the whole ridge in the
in that point with constraints
and I just turn out a change to a rest
position and damn uh it is very the the
origin of the the scene
and the rest position so I can continue
modeling in this stage
oh wait so if you're saying animated the
background you animated the environment
to go by as opposed to the character
uh no uh uh I I turned this off I keep
turning these on and off so I can go
back to this world origin and can
continue working on the model but uh the
bug is is animated Zone again
I see you say he's out there somewhere
yeah yeah so yeah are you
are you uh looping the leg animation
yeah okay uh simple look a quick look
see here yeah a very quick Loop here uh
nothing fancy about it and after having
uh I just have the the body and the legs
moving and then I started working on the
secondary movements and anticipation
sorry anticipations yes uh like moving
the the wings uh moving the second body
like this here uh moving the antennas
I keep adding stuff and when I get tired
of animating I go back to modeling do a
new uh more details go back to the
camera if it's working
and this went through all the the
process
that's great so you get tired of one
aspect you move on to another yeah
you're excited for yeah yeah I like to
very very in the production because one
thing that the major thing uh that my
first thought uh before I joined this
this challenge was I don't want to get
stressed I want to have fun I don't I
don't wanna burn out doing this yeah and
yeah and and I took it really serious uh
your suggestion in one video uh don't
rush to start don't rush to finish and I
get this in my mind for a hood over here
I think that was Ronin
it was I think it was one of the
moderators when they were doing the
rules they they added that bit and I
thought that was like really good really
good advice so I can't take credit for
that but I agree with it wholeheartedly
um yeah yeah that's good
it is so easy uh for you to get
overwhelmed with the amount of work and
you trying to go to ambitious baths that
you
you just realized that you went into a
production trap just later on so I I
really wanted to avoid this how did you
what is possible
uh plain simple uh start simple uh I I
didn't think about the second bug before
the second week
so I thought well I'll do this bug I'll
do this environment I will make him
running through this environment and see
how it goes um if I have enough time I I
will try to figure out the second book
yeah and uh
yeah no pressure at all uh I wasn't
pressuring myself in in of course uh the
the amount of time I had to do this uh
was very helpful because I I I I could
start it since the beginning
and and yeah uh I think that's
for example uh in the model uh I almost
all the time was looking at the camera
when I was modeling
and for example I have this I started
thinking in some smaller engines for
each pair of legs
and I just started to think well maybe I
put some heat scenes over there some
bold stuff like that and stop it hell no
it doesn't mean it won't notice at all
so yeah yeah no worries I just put in
the camera
make it look there oh man just crash
awesome
all good all good
okay no problem
is that windows 11.
yeah how do you like it but that
uh it is nice it is good actually I was
working in Windows 10 yeah uh when I do
this Challenge and was crashing a lot so
well maybe I will give Windows 11 a try
new updated Windows versions halfway
through this project
no no I finished first oh I finished her
I was like two crazy
no no no so you like it first you like
it I'm skeptical but I you know yeah uh
yeah uh I tried before uh right in the
beginning uh wasn't very good now I
think it feels the same okay it is very
stable cool and yeah oh no no it goes uh
actually I I also uh updated latest
version of blender but I'm using the the
same one I use in the The Challenge I
see
uh so like you can see it is all
occluded with shadows so you won't see
much details in here yeah and actually
uh you know texture stuff uh I didn't
make a huge amount of work today in
small pieces and stuff like that I I did
a gen architecture with procedural uh I
don't even UV this model
nice man it looks beautiful it's very
like it's just metal right and some
imperfections yeah it works it works uh
it definitely looks better if I have uh
spend more time on it maybe uh
going to substance painter
but well uh this geometry is at dance so
uh UV this is kind of a headache yeah I
don't UV anything
I don't even barely know how so I yeah
oh well it is a good solution are you
being uh you can
um you can solve a lot of stuff not UV
actually I think it is only for a very
specific stuff that uh uh nowadays I use
something
yeah yeah I see I see so you have you
have your animation you have your basic
texture
you know where does where do you find
yourself now week and a half two weeks
uh well I
kind of finished the
the bug model and the the pilots
environments in two weeks cool
um of course I kept you refining this
later uh the second book
uh I model him in about two days and
work on the animation maybe in four days
I I it took three weeks total to finish
the the animation yeah uh but I still
had two weeks ahead of me uh before the
deadline so I'll
keep it a rest
stay cool
don't watch this animation at this far
one day or two and then go back and I
tweak something change the contrast a
little bit change the colors a little
bit in DaVinci uh change the animation a
little bit something like that but not
nothing major but the whole process took
me three weeks total
it's great to be in a point where
you could submit and so many people
would submit you know we had people
submitting as soon as the submission
link was live two weeks after the
announcement uh
I think like to me it makes no sense
you know like yeah I you know I get I
get it if you if you have to submit and
you're gonna go on vacation or something
sure or if it's just you know you had
your time as fun and you're moving on
and that's fine
but if you have the extra time why not
sit on it and make it better where you
can
yeah I I just uh want I just wanted to
avoid delivery uh too late a bit oh yeah
two days before I think it is uh a
little
dangerous
definitely because uh yeah because I I I
I didn't I didn't participate before in
this challenge so I don't know how it
works maybe I don't know if it has any
uh bandwidth
I don't know yeah some technical issue
that might have I don't know but uh I
kept kept safe but one other thing is if
you kept
if you keep this work and don't deliver
it uh you always find something new to
work on so there was a there is a time
that you have to know how to stop and
just send the work and I'm done
because if I kept it I I send the work
one week before and I knew if I didn't
do this I would drag this until the very
end try to change some stuff and do some
crazy thing and
start getting trouble yeah you because
at a certain point you're tweaking
things just to tweak things because you
can and it's not necessary and uh it
maybe gets worse at a certain point and
I think it's important to be aware of
that
um and good on you for
for delivering it when you did
um with a week left because
I mean hey that's a good that's a good
reason right there if it's if you think
it's done and yes then it's done yeah
of course uh well it is a balance right
uh from uh everything is a balance you
you need to know how to stop and because
I I think the you never finish a work
you just don't have more time to yeah to
work on more on it so uh I I had some
um
personal projects that took forever
because I I constantly changing stuff
and yeah oh no not this time
that's smart man how long have you been
working in 3D for
oh I work for 3G for quite some time I
work for 20 years that's a long time
yeah yeah that's a long time
um what got you interested in 3D
well uh I got fascinated by uh when I
watched Toy Story and also Jurassic Park
there are very opposite Medias uh one
very realistic you want more cartoonish
but I I like both that's awesome
and start getting interested and made uh
some courses of course at the time uh
that wasn't too many courses available
uh there wasn't YouTube yet so it's a
little more difficult to gather
information about softwares but yeah I
manage it
start from there
that's great what are we looking at here
what is this yeah this is the final
scene
this is the final scene we've all
together
I love the Blazing real time but yeah
the sense of speed you have with the
rocks in the ground and the motion blur
whipping by is so nice I love that
yeah it is nice to give a depth to the
scene right uh things going really close
to the camera and things going far away
it is nice to have this different I hope
that blender doesn't crash but I will
it's okay
well well um we have about five more
minutes here we can ask the chat if you
guys have already questions I know right
it's time flies man yeah um if you have
any questions for Fabricio do at
Punisher I'll see them uh and we'll ask
him some questions here
let's see
right here
ah man it looks so nice that was so nice
yeah blender's real time it's Evie
that's what it's called the real time
renderer
no no this is Cycles uh I was yeah the
Cycles is the best racing
um yeah the most demanding one but I I
managed to work on the a lot of
optimization stuff on this on this scene
so it doesn't
it is not too heavy to work okay
what was your final render time do you
know
uh it took about seven hours
like my numbers take 48 hours
it's ridiculous
oh man
um let's see all right well uh MDK he's
asking what was the first 3D software
you ever used
I use 3D Studio not the max it is with
3D Studio before the windows version was
Fiji studio for dos
dang this is the first one the first one
I I the first few parts I saw
what was the second one
I tried LightWave uh for a little time
but
um I think it would discontinue it but I
jumped to 3das Max yeah right after and
get get with 3ds Max until today I use
this 3ds Max as well but I really like
blender
yeah yeah
yeah 3ds Max was like the one back in
the day
uh let's see we got some other questions
here if you see any ones that you want
to answer to go free
um
see
uh what's your GPU that's what wondrous
wants to know yeah uh well when I finish
this project I was using are the RTX
3090 and now I I have a 49. I just
upgraded
nice
um let's see let's see uh so we kind of
got into this a little bit but um how do
you keep yourself motivated through the
project
well uh you have to pick something you
like to do and
for when when I do personal stuff I
usually try to do something different uh
something that I I don't know that much
that I like to to study a little more
uh but my for my daily work I usually
stick with whatever they have a good
a good knowledge on it
uh and and it is nice uh when when they
the idea comes uh I think it is a very
straightforward
you you have to keep looking at
references and uh try to figure out how
how the the outcome will be when you
finish this one and of course not not
all the time it works but uh I
I
don't I don't remember how many projects
I dropped
yeah because I was too ambitious or
something that I
just lost interest
that's really really fast it's very
important to yeah yeah find that right
balance there
um yeah definitely trial and error
um
they're saying how you create a decal
the decals on the bug but I don't see
any decals are there decals on the bug
uh no no there is no decals uh there are
insert meshes uh I use a program called
uh sorry yeah I don't call a mesh
machine
and let me open one here really quick
it is really really good
um let me see let's use the cylinder
and uh subdivide it
maybe three
and use this
like here this plugs
and you just
oh I'm sorry I messed it up something
but I get the idea that's really
powerful
yeah that is very useful let me see if
it works on top of here yeah and it
inserted the mesh oh it is embedded to
the mesh oh
very nice
that is great jeez thank you for that
that's a nice nugget for everybody
good question
man yeah those holes and stuff all that
stuff is tough um yeah all these models
they use this whole uh this uh inserts
here are mesh machine
and you also can can make custom ones
like uh this curve here and this
triangle uh eye model separated and then
you said using this atom
dang yeah because that'd be really hard
to get right uh
yeah accurate topology would be tough
there but that's super cool love that
yeah
um Fabricio that that's that's all the
time we got today man but um awesome
thank you so so much for for doing this
and for being patient I know you were
you were last year you had to wait for
all the all the other ones here but
thank you yeah thank you so much for
having me thank you so much for choosing
me as the first place is I really are on
honor absolutely man yeah absolutely uh
congratulations again I love your
mindset thank you very much the workflow
and um I'll See You in September for
camp in Colorado yes
over there
um do you play any music
on the instruments no okay no
unfortunately I would like to but I no
all good I prefer to hear it we're gonna
have some good times man's very good
time okay
all right Fabricio have a good one I'll
catch you later man thank you thank you
very much peace out bye later bye
oh man so good so good
I'm so glad that we did this I was on
the fence about doing this stream
because I was really trying to limit the
amount of streams I was doing this year
really trying to reconnect with the
things I loved this year
um and uh I wanted to kind of lighten my
load for these challenges of course
we're still doing the challenges the
next one's in August all right so get
ready for that
um Mark the calendars August should be
the working month but um yeah I just
wanted to go a little easier on myself
you noticed that I didn't live stream
every single weekend and
I didn't even make a piece of art this
time around I you know I did a little
intro stuff
um I did some like intro title Graphics
next week next week and Saturday I'm
gonna be doing a breakdown for how I put
that uh motion blurred Road together
with the wet pavement and um get into
some cool tips and tricks on that
that'll be next weekend but my point is
um
I'm glad that we did this stream
because I I almost didn't
um but I re I asked myself hey
I want to know I I want to know I wanna
I wanna interview these guys I want to
find out their creative process I'm very
much involved with like trying to figure
out what my creative process is what's
the healthiest creative process
um and and the I I feel inspired I
really do it
so good so good seeing other people's
workflows
because it gets you out of your head and
it gets you thinking a different way and
I personally really need that
um and I'm sure if I need it some of you
do too so I hope you guys learned a lot
doing this uh and hanging out with me
today
um
but uh I'll I'll chill out for the next
10 minutes with you guys and uh
answer any questions that you guys have
in the chat happy to hang out with you
guys for that time
pull up a chair
ah
foreign
thank you guys for
hanging out with me camera is glitching
out a little bit but you know it's all
good
oh yeah
all right
hit me with that app Punisher
here
in the chat and I'll see what we got uh
weekly challenge
unfortunately we're not doing the weekly
challenge at this time
um I've been so used to doing them uh
like after the weekend
and it's very rare that a weekly
challenge times up with a live stream
honestly it went right over my head so
apologies
um
but I'll get you up we'll get you on the
Discord
uh like on Monday or something
all right let's see what we got here
questions questions
how do I text your stuff if I don't use
UVS well it comes with UVs
um usually stuff comes with a mesh UV
when you spawn something and you start
modeling but then you'll notice oh no as
soon as I start adjusting this primitive
the UVS are off so I always set my UVS
to just uh box or cube or flat
um
that's it I never like do any tweaking
to it
because
um
I honestly just don't know how which
might sound ridiculous
but uh
and I didn't really care to
to look it up you know I've gotten good
results from just switching it to box
you know and then it looks fine
will there be another challenge of
course there'll be another challenge
August is the working month
this August
uh Platinum you're welcome you're very
welcome I think it's an important stream
for sure I was feeling it I was feeling
it so it had it you know we're doing it
how many people submitted for this
challenge we had 4 280 people submit for
this challenge
um
which is ridiculous
that's a lot of people
um
and totaling up all of the the
collective work we had 30 years of art
three decades worth of of submissions of
working hours that is excluding render
time and excluding
any hours that went beyond because
people would put like 40 million hours
like
I basically took I added up how many
hours if you if you worked eight hours a
day
um
uh for a working week
full-time on this
for the five weeks that this challenge
was open
what that number was I basically took
any any hours plugged in higher than
that and I brought them all down to that
number and then that was what got us
because I think it was 40 years and then
I plugged that in and it came down to 30
years I just wanted to be a bit more
accurate
uh let's see
[Music]
hmm
have I tried doing any composition and
fusion inside of DaVinci not really but
I want to learn that is something that I
want to learn
how many years of render time I hadn't
tallied that up
um
I hadn't tallied that up I do not I
don't know the answer to that one
uh
you guys let's see
where can you go if you oh visual get
out of here dude
that setup that prompt where can you go
if you want to join art challenges every
single week well
uh I got a Discord server and it's
linked in the description and uh myself
and the moderators we hold these weekly
challenges every single week
uh with new prompts every week it's like
art um sorry it's like uh inktober right
where you do a sketch every day for the
month of October but it's just every
week forever basically so you can hop in
hop out whenever you want
um we're always doing weekly challenges
we I think last year we implemented like
a badge system where kind of like
Pokemon where you know as you as you
as you win the weekly challenges there's
five winners every week and honorable
mentions get points too and even get
points for participation you get like a
little a little emblem next to your name
on Discord and like you level up and go
through the ranks
uh and it's pretty pretty fun we had a
good time designing those that was cool
how do you feel about the success of
this creative Journey so far of this
creative Journey uh I mean the
challenges I guess man the challenges
have been really freaking awesome I had
no idea that we would be doing these
we we just finished our sixth challenge
and it it's everything man it like
time and time again it constantly
inspires me seeing all of your awesome
art
I love going through all the renders
that's the best time with the moderators
we go through all the renders together
and we just have a blast
um and then pulling the top 100 is
always tough pulling the top 20 is
harder pulling the top five is even
harder and putting them in an order is
even harder
um
but uh it's it's really inspiring to me
like I I truly feel very inspired right
now
um
and that gets me excited that really
does get me excited because
all last year I'll be honest all of last
year I did not really feel inspired
uh to do anything to do any art
all the art that I was putting out
was like I was on autopilot and uh I I
did a lot of cool stuff in Unreal Engine
but
I just ended up doing the same thing
over and over and over
so I'm very excited to have gone through
another challenge so got to have gotten
through it in a very healthy way
uh for me personally I'm very proud of
that
um and I feel more inspired than I had
in in a last couple of years to be
honest
and I am excited to really just
you know listen to what I want to do
listen to the things that I think are
fun and doing them whether or not it can
be monetized that is the biggest thing
having a YouTube channel is like
you know it's my it's my living it's
what pays the bills here
and um
it's scary there's a lot of pressure
we're talking about pressure right it's
a lot of pressure
to
uh to have on you when you you know
you gotta put out a video and it's got
to get x amount of views and you gotta
attach a sponsor to it and if it doesn't
get this many views then the sponsors
will stop start falling off and then
but oh you know oh but that's successful
and and but now you're just doing the
same thing
day in and day out and then you start to
lose passion lose your passion and that
is terrifying
um yeah and like I said I was kind of
faced with that last year
so I'm telling you I'm telling you all
this book right here has been
so much for me in the last month but the
artist's way that's another book too
that's one that really
it's really helping out
um
so I've kind of been reconnecting with
the stuff that I love and I know when
I'm I'm kind of off on a tangent here
from that question
but uh yes you know how's the creative
process only so far so
the journey
um I'm excited you know basically from
now until August of of uh later this
year until the next challenge
I'm just gonna do whatever I wanna do
that's fun and
you know uh figure it out from there
so right now I'm loving music
oh man I'm loving loving making music
right now there's no pressure to it I
don't have to monetize oh but getting
back to the monetization thing it's like
you feel like you have an idea
a good idea it's like oh I gotta
monetize it ah but I can't really
because I don't think the audience is
gonna like it ah I'm not gonna do it
worst mindset ever I realized that
that's what is blocking me from
from creating the stuff that I want to
do so I just gotta forget about
making a living which is terrifying
and just do it because it's fun and know
that good things will come from it
um I can't second guess it you know so
that's tough that's tough but that's
kind of where I'm at right now I'm just
like
you know
uh it's kind of what yeah it's what I
it's what I need to do so I'm excited
for it yeah I'm excited for it I've been
playing been reconnecting with
basketball actually been playing a lot
more basketball
which I used to play as a kid
um but I started playing recently
and it's
so much fun oh man it is so much fun
uh terrifying but very very fun
see oh you're asking where can I find
your music where can I find your music
I'm so hesitant to like put it up
somewhere
God forbid monetize it I just want it to
be a
personal creative thing I don't wanna
start hearing oh your music's good oh
your music's bad it's like
I just want to keep it as pure as
possible
technically it's on SoundCloud
that's all I'll say
it's on SoundCloud
um
but I'm just putting it there so I don't
have to upload it to Discord to show
friends I can just send them a
SoundCloud link you know I'm just doing
it for friends you know just trying to
show Friends stuff but yeah if you can
find it on Soundcloud then you can find
it
uh I'm not using FL Studio no I'm not
using Ableton though it would be Ableton
I have it downloaded but I honestly I'm
just
like I said
I'm I like being Hands-On with my stuff
so I don't want to be like sitting here
behind a computer clicking that is not
inspiring for me I want to be on a drum
set I want to be on the top of a
mountain with a flute I want to be
twisting knobs
on a synthesizer
um not in this chair this chair is like
I I don't want to say cursed but it's
like
it's not really inspiring I'm not
inspired sitting here behind the
computer you know like I do that for 3D
art and I'm I'm trying to re-inspire
myself on that angle right so what I've
been doing music wise actually I'll show
you guys
this
this thing's the best man
I'll play you I'll play you a little
thing
ah so it boots up
let me pull up the
let's see let's see let me pull up the
Discord really quick
so I can get the live feed going
yep okay it's a little bright
[Music]
all right cool soda's gonna remove Some
Noise filters
who knows how good this this will sound
it's gonna be you know you know I got a
speaker right here hold on
[Music]
all right so this is called an op1
and it's the best I love it so much
and it's a it's like a Nintendo switch
but for it's a portable doll
uh so you can sample things with a line
in you it has a microphone up here you
can attach a microphone like I have my
h4n like this guy
so I'll go outside and I'll just like
start recording the sound of a bird or
something and then put it into here and
give it Reverb and delay and then I just
make a lot of ambient music really uh
it's very peaceful just go to the park
and
record the birds and record the air and
add some like
some chords to it you know
it's really fun
all right
let's see
yeah Okay so yesterday I just was behind
the drum set right I was
chilling and
let's see if this sounds good I don't
know how good this is gonna Sound audio
wise like on the music the music's
perfect right no I'm just kidding
um but let's see
let's see what I can do I'm gonna mix it
up here so I got these four four tape
tracks four tape tracks if I hit play
[Music]
and you can like solo
individual tapes
and this is just recorded a little hand
pan or not handpan but little
little drum I got and I'm just recording
this with my h4n with that other that
other mic I showed you guys and then you
just add layers right so the next layer
[Music]
the next layer
it's too much fun
it's too much fun I'll show you another
thing
uh
uh let's see oh this song this is the
one that I started putting together last
night I was just uh
taking all of the PlayStation boot up
sounds and then uh like altering them
and making a song with it so
I hadn't I don't know what this sounds
like
because I was literally doing this
without without the uh here we'll just
hit play
[Music]
so then you can mess with like
the different layers so it has like a
mixer here too
right so you can start taking down
one layer
[Music]
you know I love ambient music guys so
much
there's here the PS3
a little bit a little bit of PS1 with
some PS3 in there
[Music]
and then you work in that PSP you get
the PSP going
[Music]
too much fun
so I'm like trying to get off the
computer onto this out into the park and
just making music or something you know
it says
I love it I love it I love it
um
so I'll probably put some album stuff
together at some point and release some
stuff but right now I'm just
experimenting having fun
um
let's see what else do I want to show
you guys anything else
oh I got this one this one's called
flute techno
so I have this flute
let me bust out the flute
sorry this just turned into like
let me talk about all the stuff I'm
excited about which is a good thing it's
a good thing so this is called a nay
this is a an Arabic nay it was a it's a
swamp read basically and it's uh like
two it takes two years to dry
and then it's cut by
this master I forget his name
but his signature is right there
Arab instruments I believe is where I
got this from
and uh it's got this back hole that you
cover
with your thumb
and it just has this awesome desert
flute sound let's see if I can this took
me a month to even produce a squeak from
it's really tough to play
so I preface that
before I play it
and it's there's four octaves on this
thing four octaves which is crazy
see I can barely produce a sound it's
nuts
foreign
[Music]
the lower notes are tough to hit
foreign
it's been a minute since I played this
one I can tell
you gotta get your mouth in the perfect
place anyway
let's see what flute techno sounds like
Let's Build It Up Let's Build It Up
[Music]
foreign
you know a little bit of that
still work in progress still work in
progress
but I've been having fun with that
anyway back to the questions y'all
um but yeah I got a drum set in the
garage that's fun I love playing drums
I've been playing drums since I was in
Middle School
um Shader thank you for
the Super Chat the Herman Miller chair
yeah this is a classic man this one's
great I remember Freddy said
uh who also has a Hermann military but
Freddie was like
dude you spend all day in your bed so
uh get a good bed
and I was like you know what that's
great advice and
um I think the same thing can be applied
for the office chair
uh luckily I got this one
third hand
so it was way cheaper
this is like way cheaper
um but agreed man yeah it's like one of
the best investments
um
um Paras okay you said the the winner um
Fabricio he said that he was modeling
and animating the insect at the same
time how is that possible I think what
he's saying is he's going back and forth
between modeling and animation back and
forth between modeling animation he's
not like modeling finishes the model 100
then starts animation finishes the
animation 100 then goes on to texturing
finishes texturing 100 I think he's
bouncing back and forth between all
these different things and he's doing it
because like he'll maybe be inspired to
model and he follows the inspiration for
as long as he can go for you know
whether it's days or hours and then
he'll switch over to another thing if
he's inspired for that if he gets stuck
or lost you know he'll he'll move on to
the next thing he's not just trying to
finish it to go to the next spot it's
all happening one after the other I
think that's what he meant by uh
you know at the same time
maybe the next challenge
should be to make art with your music
that would be crazy
I've thought about it
um I'm not there yet but I don't know
we'll see I'm gonna start slipping my
music into my videos
but for now I'll I'll uh hit up the
professionals when it comes to doing
that
fix you say you play drums since you
were four you also enjoy drums and being
creative it is the best playing drums
really is the best because
I would love to be at a point where uh
I don't know like living in like a
village setting
where all you really have to worry about
is of course the essentials food
um shelter
connection with other people around you
the community small little small little
area
and you know you'd be bored at night
you'd want some uh some interactions
some something fun to do so you would
play drums like drum circles and
I think what was the first three
instruments was the drum the voice of
course the Shaker and the flute I think
those were the ones
that was it back in the day so like it's
a very
ingrained thing and all of us is music
drums like that kind of stuff like
goes way back
um
so I I love it I could just play drums
all day long it's the best
uh there's actually a great great great
video I'm gonna link you guys
uh let's see if I can pull it up here
for y'all
to my YouTube favorites
and it's about this like some place in
Africa Maybe
and it's about how they play music
every day day in and day out when
they're working
uh in the fields when they're working
and like the iron the iron work when
they're doing like uh smithing and all
that stuff everything is done to the
beat and they produce the beat
themselves with you know just their feet
their voices whatever
and there's this great interview it's
like a 10 minute video
um
let me see if I can find it really quick
playlists
my favorites
let's see here it is here it is
I got you guys with the link
right here boom if you're into music if
you're into drums check that out
that's a cool one
but uh let's see what other questions we
have
do I have any plans for upcoming YouTube
videos yeah
um
let's see what can I what can I mention
um I love I love photo scanning
um so I I want to do a couple things
with that
um
some some photo scanning videos this
year uh the people over at uh
uh capturing reality is the company
reality capture is the program uh are
super nice super cool so
um planning on doing some cool stuff
with them this year
uh
uh you know there's just some videos
that I have in my head we'll see if
you know what what they what they come
about and see if they come about but uh
I think that's that's the most I can say
of course the challenge in August will
be doing another challenge in August
chicken NPC yes that is the Lego tree in
the background
I should have had the Sakura leaves on
this thing
um
because it is soccer season
uh let us see
yeah cool photo scanning is cool man I
got a couple videos on it if you want to
check those out but uh
it's fun you can do it for free these
days
yeah yeah scanning rocks is always a
blast oh man so NAB uh is coming up if
you guys are anyone here going to NAB
give me a thumbs up in the chat if
you're gonna be NAB give me a thumbs up
I'll be there on Monday
uh I'll be on the show floor on Monday
around the Maxon booth and uh I'm not
presenting or anything I'm just gonna be
hanging out for support
uh I'll be there Monday Tuesday
Wednesday evenings for all of the
dinners and uh little after party stuffs
um but I'm gonna be rock climbing in Red
Rock on Tuesday and Wednesday all day
since we'll be out in Vegas and I cannot
wait we're gonna do we're gonna try and
do nine pitches which is basically
you climb up to an anchor Point your
partner climbs to you
you climb to another Anchor Point your
partner climbs to you and we do that
nine times
so we'll see we'll see how that goes I'm
very excited for it
um
yes this is from destining
let's see let's give a little
little distracting love here I got my
boy chilling
this guy is very
very
delicate oh I'm terrified just holding
this up
yeah
this could fall apart in minutes
you look at it just teetering
oh so sketch
yeah my buddy Devon got this for me I
think for a
birthday or Christmas or something
love it
[Music]
Good Times
oh
y'all
all right this is the last Quest I'm
gonna answer this one this last question
then I'm gonna bounce and get some food
here but uh
Isaac you say what what motivated me to
start 3D
the first time I ever messed around with
3D I mean I
I remember like I always loved going to
art class I always loved drawing
and um
that eventually led me to like uh I also
loved Airsoft and like playing army I
was the kid in the neighborhood when I
was like seven or eight decked out in
full like military gear I had like a
wooden bazooka I had like helmets and
Camo Nets and belts and gear and I was
just this like little kid
that was me in the neighborhood that was
just me and I would like hide in the
bushes and spy on cars with like my
binoculars as they would go by just
patrolling you know just patrolling the
neighborhood
um
and I like wanted to join the Marines
for the longest time
um I had a lot of friends whose parents
were were in the military and uh that
was like my thing I wanted to do that
all the way up until High School
and so I kind of mixed that with like
drawing and kind of put them together
and started adding muzzle flashes to
like gun Airsoft videos you know little
like War scenes I always loved like
Saving Private Ryan
uh Behind Enemy Lines like all those
movies and uh I would try and recreate
these like War scenes and I'm like oh I
gotta add the gunshots and the muzzle
flashes so I started like painting in
muzzle flashes in like just the frame
I'd save the frame out from Windows
Movie Maker I'd bring it into like
macromedia fireworks is what the program
was called
um
it wasn't even wasn't even Photoshop and
then I would import the frame back in to
Windows Movie Maker and there would be a
muzzle flash there like in the video and
I was like oh so crazy and like it adds
sound effects and stuff so I started
getting like
you know deep into that and stuff and
then eventually uh
you know 3D was always like a big
roadblock for me it was like oh man
I need to learn how to do that stuff
it's crazy and it was just like
I remember being in high school like
must have been 10th grade
there was a program called Wings 3D it
was like this free like browser-based 3D
program and during lunch break we would
go and like just sit in the library on
the computers and mess around in this
program Wings 3D with like a couple
other guys from school and we would just
build stuff uh all next to each other
we'd be modeling next to each other and
I like
you rarely get that at least me now like
I'm just it's just me in my office but
having a group setting a group
environment is so helpful
um it's one of the great things about
you know about Corridor is
you know you have people at all these
computers you'd be doing stuff together
working on a project together it's fun
um or any job where you go into the
office and work on creative stuff is fun
so we would do that and um
at a certain point you know I discovered
uh video co-pilot and was going through
all those tutorials and uh
you know he started doing like 3D
integration tutorials there's like a
meteor strike thing he did with a hole
in the ground I was like man this is
next level I gotta get on this so then I
got uh c4d release 10 r10
and I just started modeling stuff like
modeling
like hard surface kind of stuff was
really what I loved and I watched these
tutorials by these two guys uh
Chris Tate and Ben Tate and they made
these tutorials on cgtuts.com or it's
like 3dts.com or something
and they had the best tutorials that was
for 3ds Max on how to model in 3ds Max
and I I just ate those up I love that so
much
and I was like how do I integrate it
into the into the videos
and that was always a big question for
me and like Freddy
he was the one who hopped on with me and
showed me how Buju worked which was this
like crazy Advanced tracking program
and Sam and Nico too you know they were
in 3ds Max all at the time with Brandon
and Freddy and uh they would hop on like
uh
some voice call Skype and we would uh
they would show me how it works I still
didn't quite understand and eventually I
just moved out back out to California
and
kind of started figuring things out and
yeah just connecting with the people
that that I love that were doing the
things that I loved and
yeah I just kept kept following this
kept following the passion so
um
that's a long answer to your question
but
that was fun appreciate it uh guys I
should bounce thank you for hanging out
with me it was a good time it's good to
stream with you guys again
I really enjoyed this I really really
enjoyed this so thank you guys uh
that was a good time I am gonna bounce
I'm gonna get some food
maybe I'll get some drums in maybe I'll
get some flute and oh man I gotta finish
that PS2 Jam
so many fun things to do all right guys
uh next weekend okay next weekend I have
an art breakdown for the like intro
animation I did for the top 100 Montage
so I'm gonna get into
um
you know essentially how to make a how
to make a really cool intro graphic for
like a title thing it's like an abstract
render uh lots of it's a very simple
scene but I'm kind of breaking it down
in in detail for you guys uh and I'll be
going over a lot of fun stuff like uh
hdris I'll be going over IES lights I'll
be going over uh camera Shake how to get
realistic camera Shake I'll be going
over uh
um uh realistic lighting building a
scene from the ground up I'll be talking
about uh camera settings Aces motion
blur
um
what else what else oh yeah uh like
reflective streets how to get a
realistic reflective Street going uh
uh yeah so I I'm excited how to get
something looking really nice in a very
small amount of time so that's what I'll
be talking about
next weekend guys so
if you're not subscribed if you're not
Scribd then consider scribbing
I think you have to say that right as a
YouTuber you got you have to and you
have to like say oh you got to hit the
bell too
all right guys I'ma bounce Ronan I like
it have a creative weekend
have a creative week
I'll see you guys next week see you on
the server we'll be doing the weekly
challenge
uh
uh I'll announce the winners on Monday
most likely I'm gonna take my weekend
here
and uh yeah
have a good one guys have a good one
I'll catch you later peace
[Music]